jetzt rufe ich auf die einzelpläne 0
bundesministerium der finanzen ist der
einzelplan 08 mit der
beschlussempfehlung des
haushaltsausschusses auf den drucksachen
1608 und
1626 berichterstattung haben die
abgeordneten dr thorsten rudolph doktor
ingeborg gräßle sven christian kindler
christoph meyer wolfgang wille und dr
gesine lötzsch und für den
bundesrechnungshof das ist der
einzelplan 20 mit der
beschlussempfehlung des
haushaltsausschusses auf der drucksache
berichterstattung haben die abgeordneten
dr ingeborg gräßle doch da thorsten
rudolph felix banaszak frank schäffler
ulrike schilke ziesing und dr gesine
lötzsch für die aussprache wurde eine
dauer von 90 minuten vereinbart
ich eröffne die aussprache und das wort
hat als erstes dr mathias middelberg für
die cdu csu fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen
wir erleben eine denkwürdige
haushaltswoche wieder mit einem
bundeshaushalt in rekord größenordnung
von annähernd 500 milliarden in einer
ebenso
denkwürdigen zeit
in einer zeitenwende zeit wie der
bundeskanzler das zu recht betont hat
corona pandemie klimawandel
rekord-inflation die höchste seit 40
jahren und ukraine krieg von der
zeitenwende
denkt man müsste man in ihrem haushalt
auch sehr deutlich etwas merken man
merkt aber nur etwas auf der
einnahmeseite oder sagen wir besser bei
den fehlenden einnahmen dass sie nämlich
mit den schulden in rekordhöhe nach oben
wandern
konsequent müssten sie eigentlich auf
der ausgabenseite arbeiten als
verantwortliche haushälter und als
verantwortliche finanzminister lindner
selbst vor dem ukraine krieg und selbst
noch nicht mal in ansehung der vollen
inflations größenordnung haben sie haben
sie in ihrem koalitionsvertrag
vereinbart alle aufgaben auf den
prüfstand zu stellen und sie haben auch
vereinbart im rahmen des haushalts
ausstellungs verfahrens auch
ausgabenkürzungen vorzunehmen
eine richtige vorgabe wie wir finden
nennenswerte priorisierung oder
kürzungen sind allerdings in ihrem
haushalt nicht erkennbar
im gegenteil
die satteln einfach nur drauf
netto 6000 zusätzliche stellen im
personalbereich darüber könnte man an
der einen oder anderen stelle noch
diskutieren aber sie lassen sich es auch
selbst gut gehen sie diskutieren wir
alle diskutieren darüber ob wir das
parlament verkleinern sie machen es sich
selber in der regierung richtig fett mit
der rekordzahl von 37 parlamentarischen
staatssekretären in dieser größenordnung
hat es bisher noch keine bundesregierung
geschafft
und ihre fortschritts koalition setzt
auch in anderen feldern maßstäbe sie
sind gestartet
mit zusätzlich und reichlich
zusätzlichen beamten in den ministerien
in der spitze der ministerien in den
teuersten besoldungsstufen vor vier
jahren haben sie der alten großen
koalition vorgeworfen als wir 200
stellen aufgebaut haben wer so anfängt
sagte der kollege fricke der
haushaltssprecher der fdp wer so anfängt
macht am ende aus einer schwarzen null
ein schwarzes loch der satz war ja gar
nicht so falsch aber er trifft auf sie
noch viel härter zu sie bauen jetzt 324
neue stellen top stellen in den
ministerien auf das ist mal ganz
deutlich mehr als alle
vorgängerregierungen
von zeitenwende reden sie aber sie
wenden nichts nicht in ihrem haushalt
den kernhaushalt da ist der
verschuldungs anteil 140 milliarden dann
haben wir gemeinsam dafür sage ich an
dieser stelle auch herzlichen dank dass
schlecht ich gerne ein das
sondervermögen bundeswehr 100 milliarden
neue schulden und dann haben sie noch
die 60 milliarden die bis gut aus der
letzten wahlperiode die sie tatsächlich
als diebesgut diese kreditermächtigung
leben sie mit rüber
und wenn man das dann auf addiert man zu
300 milliarden neuen schulden ja die 60
milliarden müssen wir ehrlich bei ihnen
rein rechnen das sind 300 milliarden
schulden und das ist der absolute rekord
bisher
so dann haben sie viele projekte die das
bürgergeld die kindergrundsicherung und
das klima geld das er heilen wir jetzt
ins gespräch bringt ist alles im
haushalt noch nicht abgebildet da sind
wir mal sehr gespannt aber das
wichtigste ist eigentlich und das größte
und bemerkenswertes zu versorgen ist
sie haben für den ganzen bereich der
sozialversicherung keine wirkliche
vorsorge getroffen und das wird in den
nächsten jahren und jahrzehnten das
drückende problem werden wir haben in
diesem land
vollbeschäftigung und wir haben auch
rekordbeschäftigung mit 45 millionen
beschäftigten die in die sozialkassen
einzahlen trotzdem sind wir nicht in
anlagen daraus die rente zu finanzieren
wir können die krankenkasse nicht
finanzieren wir können die pflege auch
nicht finanzieren so und ich sag das
durchaus sie brauchen gar nicht so
brüllen dürfen ich sag das durchaus
selbstkritisch auch wir haben in der
letzten großen koalition dieses problem
das schon
der unterschied ist nur folgender ihr
bundeskanzler der heute nicht hier ist
hat mit diesem thema wahlkampf gemacht
er hat respekt gefordert oder respekt
angeboten gegenüber den wählern und er
hat gesagt ich bin der kanzler ich bin
der kanzler klebten ihre plakate in der
ganzen republik stolz drauf ich bin der
kanzler für sichere renten sie haben für
gar nichts vorgesorgt im bereich
sicherheit der renten sie haben nur
gesagt das rentenniveau bleibt das
gleiche an den beiträgen ändern wir
nichts und das rentenalter ändern wir
auch nicht wie wollen sie das problem
dann lösen das problem können sie nur
lösen indem sie immer mehr steuergelder
in die rente schaufeln sie haben
überhaupt keine vorsorge getroffen um
dieses kernthema irgendwie zu bewältigen
das ist die
unverantwortliche und verantwortlichkeit
par excellence in der haushaltspolitik
und das wird sie einordnen und wir
werden sie zukunft daran regelmäßig
erinnern und daran auch messen wenn
dieser kanzler respekt gegenüber seinen
wählern hat dann müsste er sich ganz
zügig und zwar grundlegend systems
themas reformierung der
sozialversicherung annehmen
letzter punkt
entlastungspaket dafür wollen sie sicher
wahrscheinlich auch feiern lassen
möglicherweise auch heute die
entlassungs pakete gehen aber bei ihnen
nicht nach dem motto das sie da
entlasten wo es wirklich zielgenau
erforderlich wäre da wo die belastungen
am größten sind sondern sie belastet sie
entlasten so dass jeder von ihren ampel
partnern jeder ampel partei kriegt so
ein bisschen was der eine die ist der
andere das und am ende sind sie dann
fröhlich und nach der zielgerichteten
entlastung der bürger wird nicht gefragt
und die findet auch nicht statt dies
sogar im kern ungerecht und deswegen
fordern wir dass auch pendler adäquat in
diesen paketen berücksichtigung finden
und genau so auch händler studenten die
haben die gleichen belastungen und die
haben genauso entlastung von ihnen zu
erwarten
und wir
sie geben hier diese entlastung oder
sprechen darüber immer mit seiner
gönnerhaften attitüde jetzt gehen wir in
irland dies und das und ja und
vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen mehr
dann wird über dies und jenes diskutiert
sie haben massiv mehreinnahmen im moment
aus der jetzigen situation und der
finanzminister hat jedoch vor ein paar
wochen erklärt das ging alles nicht die
leute wenn sie das geld dann da nicht
hätten würden sie es gar nicht ausgeben
wir sehen doch jetzt an den
steuerschätzung sehr deutlich das laufen
steigende steuereinnahmen auf sie zu
schießen laufen steigende
steuereinnahmen
sie haben zusätzliche einnahmen aus der
umsatzsteuer im zweijahresvergleich in
der steigerung um 30 prozent gegenüber
der vorzeit sie haben zusätzliche einer
darin ganz ehrlich wir erwarten von
ihnen nicht dass die gönnerhafte
irgendetwas zurückgeben aber wir
erwarten von ihnen dass sie den menschen
das zurückgeben was ihnen vorher höhere
steuern und abgaben aus der tasche
gezogen haben das muss sein besten dank
mathias middelberg der stellvertretende
vorsitzende der unions fraktion hatte
die debatte eröffnet wir sind in der
allgemeinen finanzdebatte wir sind aber
auch beim etat des bundesfinanzministers
und diebesgut hat er gesagt zu einer
verschiebung einer kreditermächtigung
die mal geplant war um corona folgen
auszugleichen und die jetzt für projekte
des klimafonds genutzt werden soll da
gibt es auch eine entsprechende klage in
karlsruhe
nächster redner christoph meyer für die
fdp-fraktion
krisen haushalt wir dokumentieren die
notlage am freitag in time nochmaligen
beschluss nach artikel 115
wir haben viel über krisen gesprochen
über die zeitenwende diskutiert und eine
folge das sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr beschließen wir ebenfalls im
nächsten tagen und ich möchte hier ganz
klar stellen dieses sondervermögen ist
ein volk dieser chor ist ein erfolg
dieser koalition von bundeskanzler
scholz von christian linder als
verhandlungsführer aber auch von
annalena baerbock und ich danke explizit
der union dass sie hier ihrer
staatspolitischen verantwortung gerecht
geworden ist und mit uns zusammen einen
sehr guten kompromiss gefunden hat
herr mittelberg wir haben zwei
entlastungs paket geschnürt mit über 40
milliarden euro entlastungsvolumen in
den nächsten jahren und nun sagen sie
und das zieht sich wie ein roter faden
durch die beiträge der union in den
haushaltsberatungen dass es von allem
immer etwas mehr sein muss ich habe von
ihnen den haushaltsberatungen keinen
einzigen seriösen gegen
finanzierungsvorschlag gehört sie
fordern einfach nur immer mehr das ist
eine rolle als oppositionsfraktion die
wirtin irgendwann auf die füße fallen
und zur wahrheit gehört auch dazu dass
wir in den parlamentarischen beratungen
6 milliarden euro mehr für zinskosten
einstellen muss das heißt die stadt die
zeit der staatsverschuldung ohne aufwand
ist vorbei und umso wichtiger wird es
dass wir im jahr 2023 zur
haushaltspolitischen normalität
zurückkehren dreh und angelpunkt das ist
gut das können sie tun dreh und
angelpunkt ist die einhaltung der
schuldenbremse 20 23 und 20 24 25 das
werden wir in den folgejahren
sicherstellen und wenn die fdp die es in
den letzten tagen immer wieder betont
dies ist keine frage einer partei
position es ist zwingende vorgabe der
verfassung welche diese gesamte
koalition und diese ganze regierung
einzuhalten hat und daher wird auch die
gesamte koalition insgesamt auch
gefordert seien bei den ausgaben zu
priorisieren und zu konsolidieren
und wenn das statistische bundesamt
gestern eine inflationsrate von 7,9
prozent gemeldet hat wo der bund nur
bedingt gegensteuern kann auch das
gehört dazu zu sagen werden wir die
vorhandenen spielräume im herbst für
dringende entlastungen bei den
bürgerinnen und bürger nutzen müssen und
da begrüßen wir dass der arbeitsminister
am wochenende einen debattenbeitrag
geleistet hat aber für uns ist noch klar
dass zunächst der abbau der kalten
aggressionen vordergrund stehen muss ist
eine frage der gerechtigkeit dass der
staat nicht auch noch an
preissteigerungen sich bereichern darf
und profitieren darf
meine damen und herren ich möchte den
dank für sehr konstruktive
haushaltsberatungen in den ampel
fraktionen aussprechen wir werden im
juni ende juni bereits den haushalt für
das jahr 2023 im bundeskabinett haben da
geht es weiter der bundesfinanzminister
hat zu beginn dieses jahres gesagt jetzt
22 der haushalt ist primär noch eine
weiterschreiben der großen koalition
auch wenn wir viele veränderungen
vornehmen mussten an jahr 2023 an dem
haushalt können wir den finanzministern
messen lassen können wir diese koalition
messen lassen ich freue mich auf die
beratung und danke ihnen für die
aufmerksamkeit
so viel beratung gibt es nicht mehr
denn es wird ja am ende dieser woche
abgestimmt über den bundeshaushalt 20 22
wir haben also noch ein wenig debatte
dazu die beratung stattgefunden ebenso
die bereinigungssitzung des
haushaltsausschusses
peter böhringer ist am pult
haushaltspolitischer sprecher der fdp
fraktion
euro bei 1 139 milliarden
neuverschuldung das sechsfache dessen
was das grundgesetz normalerweise
erlaubt erneut wird eine haushalterische
notsituation geltend gemacht obwohl 2022
keinerlei pandemische notsituation
vorliegt in den haushaltsberatungen
wurde nicht einmal klar gestellt ob man
zur begründung der notsituation auch
immer nur corona als jahrhundert
ausnahme heranzieht oder ob nun auch der
ukraine konflikte begründung sein soll
der entsprechend klären der antrag wurde
die bundestag erst gestern abend um 21
uhr vorgelegt das ist ein unmögliches
vorgehen zumal sie selbst darin nun
nicht eindeutig klarstellen mit welcher
notstands begründung sie eigentlich
gerade an der schuldenbremse vorbei
regieren
und dieses intransparente schauspiel
wiederholt sich ja gerade auch noch beim
geplanten bundeswehr sondervermögen auch
dort war noch bis gestern abend unklar
auf welcher artikel grundlage des
grundgesetzes und mit welcher genauen
zweckbestimmung es eigentlich an diesem
freitag errichtet werden soll solch ein
gesetzgeberischer schweinsgalopp in
zentralen politik fragen mit steuer
auswirkungen im dreistelligen
milliardenbereich ist eine groteske
missachtung des parlaments
jedenfalls hätte man auch 2022 die
schuldenbremse einhalten können wenn man
die richtigen prioritäten gesetzt hätte
die von uns aufgezeigten
einsparpotenziale liegen bei mehr als
160 milliarden euro der egf bzw der
klima und transformations- hohe kann als
reine ideologie titel weitgehend
gestrichen werden
auch die sogenannte asyl klage ist
endlich aufzulösen
im einzelplan des gesundheitsministers
muss die vervierfachung des etats die
vervierfachung gegenüber 2009/10 endlich
beendet werden über 40 milliarden euro
corona ausgaben sind ohne jeden nachteil
für die bürger zu streichungen zu
streichen die zahlen an die
krankenhäuser für leerstehende betten
die kosten für tests für impfstoffe für
das offenhalten der impfzentren im
sommer das ist alles überflüssig
natürlich auch die kosten für im
propaganda die öffentlichkeitsarbeit des
gesundheitsministeriums wurde mit corona
von 5 auf 210 millionen euro
verzichten und union wollen diese
position sogar nochmals verdoppeln das
geht in ihren anträgen die afg hatte all
das schon vor über zwei jahren
gestrichen bis auf unternehmenshilfen
bis auch diese die wir als ja nationale
hilfen notgedrungen mit tragen obwohl
wir als einzige partei immer gegen die
korona maßnahmen hysterie waren immer
seit mai 20 20
minister lauterbach kauft impfstoffe für
alle denkbaren kollabieren eben ist
wieder für 830 millionen euro während
gleichzeitig dosen im milliardenwert
verfallen weiterhin geben wir milliarden
in den internationalen gesundheits
aufbau vor allem für weltweite simpson
aber auch freiwillige zahlungen an die
bh oben zudem möchte mehr ernsthaft ein
prognosemodell für impfstoff bedarf die
ampel vertritt als sie noch immer dem
absurden glauben künftige viren
pandemien voraussehen
genau die impfstoffe und der bedarf
gegen potenziell tausende von varianten
voraus planen und dafür ein modell
erstellen zu können so etwas ist einfach
nur abwegig
dann gender und klimaprogramm in aller
welt das sind die berüchtigten welt
beglückung programme der so genannten
agenda 2030 für eine demokratisch
niemals mehrheitsfähige transformation
der welt
viel geld könnte man natürlich auch bei
der eu holen wenn man es denn wollte
deutschland erhält etwa nur ein viertel
dessen was uns aus dem riesigen eu
corona programm next generation zustände
und obwohl man das weiß wird in brüssel
ohne erkennbaren widerstand aus dem
finanzministerium schon der nächste
schulden topf konzipiert nur ein jahr
nach dem präzedenzfall der eu corona
hilfen es zeigt sich dass der minister
die sagen es stimmt nicht es ist
angekündigt von frau von der leyen und
von iks anderen personen ist angekündigt
also dann bitte ich sie um eine
zwischenfrage wenn sie wirklich in
dieser form hier sagen es stimmt nicht
es zeigt sich dass der next generation
gemeinschaftsschulden topf kein
einzelfall war sondern ein dammbruch ich
sagte hier an dieser stelle schon 20 21
wenn dieser dann erst einmal gebrochen
ist dann wird brüssel immer wieder
riesige summen zu lasten deutscher
qualität aufnehmen und sie großzügig um
verteilen meine prognose ein neues eu
unterstütztes schulden programm über
hunderte milliarden euro wird kommen mit
sichtbarem deutschen anteil wie es der
finanzminister ausdrückt alle deutschen
steuerzahler werden absehbar drei bis
sechs monate arbeiten alleine nur zur
absicherung dieses sichtbaren deutschen
anteils
wir retten die ganze welt wird von
deutschland behafteten schulden aber für
die eigenen leute gibt es viel zu wenig
geld zumindest kein eu geld
und vor diesem hintergrund lesen wird
ein solche sätze des finanzministers man
kann abhängig werden von
staatsverschuldung wir müssen die sucht
nach verschuldung beenden zitat ende das
sagen sie hat nicht mehr ernsthaft
nachdem sie selbst in nur sechs monaten
im amt nun volle 200 milliarden euro
aufgenommen haben zuzüglich bundeswehr
sondervermögen wir hörten ist ja eben
schon herrn mittelberg sind es dann
sogar 300 milliarden schulden die fts
der auffassung dass auch dieser haushalt
wieder erneut verfassungswidrig ist man
darf keine notkredite aufnahmen um
rücklagen zu bilden was sie aber auch 22
erneut getan haben das ist und bleibt
ein missbrauch des ausnahme artikels
[Applaus]
diese schuldenpolitik der regierung wird
natürlich zu immer noch mehr inflation
führen auch mit dem 22er haushalt gießt
die koalition weiteres benzin ins feuer
und wo obwohl die afg natürlich die seit
jahrzehnten angelegten deflations
ursachen auch nicht über nacht aus der
welt schaffen könnte konnten wir doch
gegen die inflations folgen
weitreichende steuerentlastungen
vorschlagen und auch gegenfinanzieren
das sind die erhöhung des
grundfreibetrags das kommt fast allen
zugute auf 12.600 euro die aussetzung
der umsatzsteuer auf lebensmittel und
treibstoffe die längst fällige
allfällige und überfällige abschaffung
des solis die abschaffung der sinnfreien
co2 besteuerung all das ist
gegenfinanziert die regierung profitiert
über hohe steuereinnahmen absurderweise
von der schulden inflation die sie
selbst befeuert für die menschen dagegen
ist die inflation der große für arme
kleine leute mit nur langsam wachsenden
einkünften stehen plötzlich viel ärmer
da eine regierung die das verursacht ist
zutiefst antisozial
doch etwa die größten grünen begrüßen
sogar die inflation der hohe preis der
klima ideologie ist nun da und die
grünen finden das auch noch gut
lebensmittel ist sein eigentlich viel zu
billig und deutschland sei für die
ukraine bereit einen hohen
wirtschaftlichen preis zu zahlen zudem
beklagt frau berbalk auch noch die
kriegsmüdigkeit der menschen werden
nicht nur von abgehobene ideologen
sondern auch von zynikern regiert
peter böhringer aus der fdp-fraktion wo
ihr haushaltspolitischer sprecher ist
und haushaltspolitischer sprecher ist
auch der nächste redner der nässe oder
aus der spd-fraktion ich noch mal einen
kurzen hinweis an die mitglieder der
regierungsbank geben
zwischenrufe zwischen bemerkungen die
ich laut höre aber auch andere sind
nicht gestattet
und jetzt rufe ich den nächsten redner
auf für die spd-fraktion dennis rohde
[Applaus]
geschätzte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir
beraten in dieser woche abschließen den
bundeshaushalt
2022 und ja wir sehen noch mal eine hohe
kreditaufnahme von 139 milliarden euro
vor das sind und das gehört dann aber
auch zur wahrheit 100 milliarden euro
weniger als das was 20 21 in der großen
koalition geplant war und das hat
verschiedene gründe der erste grund ist
dass wir viele maßnahmen nicht mehr
brauchen nicht mehr finanzieren müssen
weil sich viele menschen in diesem land
solidarisch gezeigt haben sich impfen
lassen haben und den gilt allen unser
dank liebe kollegen
an der zweite grund ist
dass wir verbesserte steuereinnahmen
haben dass wir eine wirtschaft haben die
sich gerade als stabil herausstellt und
der grund liegt auch in den maßnahmen
die wir in der vergangenheit getroffen
haben dadurch dass wir arbeitsplätze
durch das kurzarbeitergeld gesichert
haben dadurch dass die unternehmen durch
wirtschaftshilfen gesichert haben stehen
wir heute so da wie wir dastehen
wesentlich besser als das was im letzten
jahr status quo war und das ist finde
ich auch ein erfolg der politik der
letzten jahre liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
aber dieser haushalt ist mit
unsicherheiten behaftet der ukraine
konflikt mit seinen verschiedensten
auswirkungen auf der ausgabeseite aber
auch auf der einnahmeseite wir wissen
nicht wie sich das wirtschaftswachstum
in der zweiten jahreshälfte entwickelt
wir wissen nicht welche auswirkungen die
inflation auf der ausgabeseite auch für
den bundeshaushalt hat wir haben eine
situation wo die zinsen steigern und wir
eigentlich mal eingeplante negativ
zinseinnahmen jetzt nicht mehr haben
also alles das was wir als
planungsgrundlage haben ist durchaus
volatil und trotzdem und gerade dessen
müssen wir uns den herausforderungen die
da auf uns zukommt stellen und ich will
das am beispiel der ukraine machen
während der bereinigungssitzung haben
die g7-finanzminister getagt während der
bereinigungssitzung hat man beschlossen
15 milliarden euro liquiditätshilfen der
ukraine kurzfristig zur verfügung zu
stellen und uns war wichtig diesen
deutschen anteil eine milliarde euro
noch in der nacht in den bundeshaushalt
zu überführen um deutlich zu machen an
dieser frage stehen legislative und
exekutive geschlossen ein zeichen der
solidarität das auch aus der
bereinigungssitzung ausdrücklicher
kolleginnen und kollegen
139 milliarden euro und soweit gehört am
ende kommen noch 100 milliarden euro
dazu nämlich das sondervermögen für die
bundeswehr um die truppe endlich wieder
vernünftig auf vordermann zu bringen und
die bundesrepublik wehrhaft zu machen
ich danke all denen die sich ihrer
staatspolitischen verantwortung an
dieser stelle stellen die dafür sorge
tragen dass diese sondervermögen
realität wird wir brauchen ist und wir
bringen es auf den weg und sind damit
auch vorbild für viele andere nationen
um uns herum liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
mein dank gilt besonders gegen
diejenigen die verhandelt haben mein
besonderer dank geht dem bundeskanzler
der die initiative angestoßen hat er
diese sondervermögen auf den weg
gebracht hat aber auch dem
finanzminister der
verteidigungsministerin der
außenministerin und den vertreterinnen
und vertreter der union die an der sache
orientiert zu einem guten ergebnis
gekommen sind in allen im namen der
spd-fraktion vielen dank
die äußere sicherheit ist prägend für
diesen bundeshaushalt weil wir da die
großen herausforderungen haben bei der
bundeswehr bei der unterstützung der
ukraine aber wir haben in der debatte
auch die anderen sicherheiten nicht
vergessen die innere sicherheit und die
soziale sicherheit wir stärken die
innere sicherheit ganz gezielt zum
beispiel durch 2000 zusätzliche
bundespolizisten und bundespolizisten
die ab 20 25 20 26 unsere bahnhöfe und
flughäfen sicherer machen werden und
dann kann man den ställen aufwuchs der
ampel kritisieren aber am ende sorgen
wir damit für zusätzliche sicherheit und
ich finde das sollte auch im interesse
der union seien drei kollegen und
und wir lernen aus der katastrophe im
aartal wir haben gemerkt welches
material den technischen hilfswerk
spielte und haben mit diesem
bundeshaushalt zum beispiel dafür
gesorgt dass dem technischen hilfswerk
zusätzliche unimog zur verfügung
gestellt werden dass die zusätzliche
logistikzentren bekommen damit sie alles
das was sie im krisenfall brauchen auch
vorhalten können auch das ist ein
beitrag für die innere sicherheit und
für den inneren zusammenhalt in diesem
land dieser politik
und wir stärken die soziale sicherheit
durch entlastungspaket mit einmal
zuschüssen durch die möglichkeit
kostengünstig den öffentlichen
personennahverkehr zu nutzen was gerade
in den nächsten wochen und monaten
vielen menschen auch ermöglicht in den
ferienzeiten zu reisen die es sich durch
die inflation ansonsten nicht mehr
leisten könnten auch ein beitrag zum
zusammenhalt durch die senkung der
energie steuern auf kraftstoffe
all das sind maßnahmen die ein ziel
haben in zeiten von krieg um uns herum
von inflation dieses land
zusammenzuhalten und diese aufgabe gehen
wir an in der ampel liebe kolleginnen
und kollegen
aber auch ein thema soziales spielt die
ukraine wieder mit rein wir stärken ganz
gezielt in die tat des
bundesarbeitsministers zum beispiel
durch die möglichkeit 200 millionen euro
zusätzlich für eingliederungsmaßnahmen
zu nutzen zum beispiel für über 100
millionen euro für zusätzliche
deutschkurse damit diejenigen die bei
uns schutz suchen auch eine perspektive
in diesem land haben und auch das ist
ein beitrag zur sozialen sicherheit
dieses landes liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen
und wir vergessen dabei nicht dass wir
nicht nur eine verantwortung für unser
land tragen ja die krisen um uns herum
sie treffen die europäische union und
sie treffen die bundesrepublik
deutschland hat aber es gibt regionen
die werden umso härter getroffen weil es
da dann teilweise und die blanke
existenz um das blanke überleben geht
und uns war es wichtig deutlich zu
machen dass wir unsere internationalen
verpflichtungen
dass wir die krisen die zb auf dem
afrikanischen kontinent entstehen mit
blick auf große ernährungsprobleme dass
wir die seen und angehen und deshalb
wird mit diesem bundeshaushalt der
bereich der entwicklungszusammenarbeit
noch mal um 2,4 milliarden euro im
vergleich zum regierungsentwurf gestärkt
das ist ein starkes signal der
internationalen solidarität dieses
bundeshaushalt
und wir vergessen auch nicht diejenigen
die es in der krise besonders schwer
hatten die kulturschaffenden zum
beispiel den ihrigen gesamte existenz
für viele monate geraubt worden wir
stärken wieder erneut die kultur in
großem umfang nicht nur bei den
investitionen wo wir kommunen und länder
unterstützen wollen dass sie das was sie
an kulturgütern halten auch erhalten
können sondern zum beispiel auch in dem
wir in diesem jahr einen zusätzlichen
zuschuss an die künstlersozialkasse
geben wollen damit im nächsten jahr der
beitragssatz stabilisiert werden kann
und die künstler die es in den letzten
jahren eh schon besonders werten nicht
dort noch doppelt hart getroffen werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
abschließend ja dieser haushalt ist mit
vielen unsicherheiten behaftet
aber er ist ausdruck unserer
gesamtverantwortung
für die äußere für die innere und für
die soziale sicherheit es ist ein
haushalt des zusammenhalts und unsere
fraktion wird dem gern zustimmen
denis rödel der haushaltspolitische
sprecher der spd fraktion betont noch
einmal äußere innere und soziale
sicherheit seien bedacht worden beim
haushalt 20 22 zumindest in einem fall
wird widerspruch zu erwarten seien von
janine wissler der vorsitzenden der
linken meine damen und herren ja dieser
haushaltswoche zeit ja ganz gut die
prioritätensetzung dieser ampel
regierung in wenigen wochen haben sie
sich mit der union darauf geeinigt auf
100 milliarden sondervermögen genauer
gesagt sondern schulden für die
bundeswehr und dazu soll jetzt das
grundgesetz geändert werden das heißt
ausrüstung soll in diesem land
verfassungsrang bekommen ich will nur
darauf hinweisen dass der
verteidigungshaushalt schon seit 2014 um
insgesamt 40 prozent erhöht wurden und
die linke wird dieses sondervermögen
dieses 100 milliarden paket und auch das
2 prozent abgerüstet aufrüstung stil wir
lehnen das ab wir werden dagegen stimmen
eine aufrüstung macht diese welt nicht
friedlicher
und was könnte einmal mit diesen 100
milliarden alles sinnvolles tun man
könnte zum beispiel alle schulen in der
bundesrepublik sanieren und sie wissen
auch dass es viele dringend nötig haben
investitionen in den klimaschutz in die
verkehrswende dafür bräuchten wir doch
dreistelligen milliarden programme und
was tun sie denn meine damen und herren
gegen die wachsende soziale ungleichheit
in diesem land die versprochene
kindergrundsicherung findet sich nicht
im haushalt ist verschoben auf 20 24 das
heißt sie haben den kampf gegen
kinderarmut um zwei jahre verschoben ich
frage sie was gibt es denn drängen da
riss als kinder und familien aus der
armut holen meine damen und herren
in der viele familien überhaupt nicht
mehr wissen wie sie ihre
wochenendeinkäufe noch bezahlen sollen
wo viele nicht wissen wie sie die
gasrechnungen bezahlen sollte oder die
immer weiter steigenden mieten da ist es
doch so dringend notwendig die kleinen
und mittleren einkommen diese menschen
zu entlasten wo sind denn die milliarden
für die pflege was wurde den
pflegekräften in der korona krise
versprochen dass es verbesserungen für
ihre arbeitsbedingungen geben soll wo
sind da die milliarden die eingestellt
sind und wir sagen ganz klar auch in
dieser krise werden eben nicht alle
ärmer es gibt einige die sehr gut
verdienen an dieser krise das sind die
krisengewinnler deswegen ist es dringend
notwendig diese exorbitant hohen gewinne
endlich vernünftig zu besteuern hoher
einkommen vermögen zur finanzierung
öffentlicher aufgaben heranzuziehen aber
das thema umverteilung ist bei diesem
finanzminister und dieser
bundesregierung leider eine lehrstelle
nächster redner für die fraktion bündnis
90/die grünen sven christian kindler
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin meine
damen und herren zehn wochen
parlamentarische arbeit an diesem
bundeshaushalt liegen hinter uns das ist
der erste haushalt der ampelkoalition
das waren sehr besondere
herausforderungen die wir hatten weil
dieser aus den zeiten großer globaler
krisen aufgestellt wurde und mit diesem
haushalt geben wir konkrete antworten
auf diese krisen wir geben konkrete
antworten auf den schrecklichen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine wir
geben antworten auf die krise des klimas
und des artensterbens gegeben auch
antworten auf die immer noch anhaltende
corona pandemie und wir geben auch
antworten auf die vor allem fossil
betriebene inflation wir geben konkrete
antwort im haus hat auf die krisen aber
wir haben auch konkret für die zukunft
vorhanden aktiv mit diesem
bundeshaushalt in dieser krise
und wir betreiben aber nicht nur aktive
krisenbewältigung sondern wir sorgen
auch für die zukunft vor wir haben die
investitionen in parlamentarischer fahne
bereinigungssitzung noch mal um 700
millionen euro erhöht und insgesamt wenn
man den energie und klimafonds
zusammennimmt den kernhaushalt und das
sondervermögen digitale infrastruktur
haben den rekordwert von investitionen
von 75 milliarden euro und diesmal
haushalt
wir konnten seit beginn der
ampelkoalition
das volumen des energie und klimafonds
für die nächsten jahre auf fast 200
milliarden euro verdoppeln und wir haben
im parlamentarischen verfahren noch mal
den national klimaschutz gestärkt wir
haben internationalen klima- und wir die
biodiversitätsschutz gestärkt wie
unterstützen urbane räume bei der
anpassung an die klimakrise wir haben
die digitalisierung der schiene mit 400
millionen euro in den nächsten jahren
gestärkt und worauf wir besonders stolz
sind wir haben auch endlich die
finanzierung für das polar
forschungsschiff polarstern 2 für das
forschungsschiff polarstern 2 endlich
gesichert das ein ganz wichtiger beitrag
die forschung aber auch für den
klimaschutz
das sondervermögen wurde schon
angesprochen es ist richtig dass während
die bundeswehr in den nächsten jahren
angemessen ausstatten und dass wir im
haushaltsausschuss auch gleichzeitig
beschlossen haben dass wir eine
notwendige reform des umschwungs wesen
eng begleiten werden zusammen mit dem
rechnungshof
und ich kann ehrlich gesagt allerdings
sich die union verstehen dass im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert cyber
abwehr kein teil des sondervermögens
sein sollte ehrlich das ist von
vorgestern liebe union
aber ich will noch etwas ich will auch
etwas lobendes union sagen ich begrüße
ausdrücklich dass die union ihre
ideologische position beim
sondervermögen geräumt hatten eine
neuverschuldung von 100 milliarden euro
an der schuldenbremse vorbei zugestimmt
hat so wird jetzt die ausstattung der
bundeswehr nicht gegen notwendige
gerechtigkeit notwendig klima zum
haushalt ausgespielt dafür danke ich
herzlich
dennis kohler des angesprochenen
sicherheit bemisst sich aber nicht nur
an die militärausgaben sondern auch die
ausgaben für diplomatie zivile
krisenprävention und
entwicklungszusammenarbeit sind zentral
für unsere sicherheitspolitik in der
einen welt wir sehen ja gerade wie
wladimir putin gezielt mit ernährung und
mit hunger einen krieg führt ein korn
trick weltweit und versucht die
internationale gemeinschaft auch zu
spalten und deswegen ist es gut dass wir
den zweiten regierungsentwurf noch mal
deutlich nachgebessert haben im
ergänzungs haushalt im parlamentarischen
verfahren
wir haben jetzt 2,7 milliarden euro mehr
für das auswärtige amt und für das bmz
bereitstellen können weil ich zentral
diplomatie und zivile krisenprävention
der kampf gegen hunger zentrale teil
unserer sicherheitspolitik sind aber wir
erwarten auch als fraktion dass die 11
regelungen die im koalitionsvertrag
festgehalten ist dass die auch für die
nächsten haushalte und der finanzplanung
deutlich abgesichert wird weil es nicht
nur in diesem haushalt große krisen gibt
sondern auch in den nächsten jahren wird
es weiterhin große krisen auch weltweit
geben und deswegen brauchen wir eine
absicherung in der finanzplanung
und die linke und die union habe es
angesprochen und immer noch mehr geld
gefordert aber ich will darauf hinweisen
dass diese koalition innerhalb von
wenigen wochen zwei entlastungs paket in
höhe von über 40 milliarden euro
bereitgestellt hat unser fokus lag vor
einigen darauf menschen gezielt zu
entlassen und menschen auch sozial
gerecht zu entlassen das haben die
entlassungs paketen auch gezeigt
und natürlich gibt es auch noch
nachbesserungsbedarf
natürlich gibt es auch in kürzerer zeit
auch nachbesserungsbedarf das will ich
ehrlich zugeben nicht alle maßnahmen
auch 100 prozent ziel genau das sehen
wir gerade bei der befristete absenkung
der energie steuer aber wenn wir jetzt
strukturell daran gehen dass wir
entlastungen auch absichern wollen dann
haben wir da am koalitionsvertrag zwei
instrumente vereinbart die auch
strukturell dauerhaft zielgerecht und
und zielgenau wirken das ist das energie
geld finanziert aus allgemeinen
haushaltsmitteln und das ist die
kindergrundsicherung und ich gehe auch
davon aus dass die absicherung
koalitionsvertrag daneben auch in der
finanzplanung abgesichert wird
natürlich können wir auch über neue wege
der finanzierung reden dafür sind wir
grüne immer gerne offen für uns ist klar
dass bei der steuerpolitik ist vor allen
dingen um eine gerechte lastenverteilung
geht und deswegen sagen wir auch sehr
klar gerade in einer krise die so
fundamentales müssen starke schultern
deutlich mehr tragen als schwache es
gilt besonders für die steuerpolitik
herr mittelberg hat den energie und
klimafonds angesprochen und die 60
milliarden euro die sie jetzt in
karlsruhe klagen das heißt 60 milliarden
euro die nicht für die notwendige
transformation der wirtschaft eine
klimaschutz bereit in den nächsten
jahren das ist ihr gutes recht werden
dass inhaltlich falsch und
verfassungsrechtlich für nicht tragfähig
was sie gemacht haben aber man kann
nicht gleichzeitig den etf und die 60
milliarden rücklagen karte beklagen und
mittelberg und dann in der
bereinigungssitzung ein antrag vorlegen
der diese 60 milliarden euro aktiviert
obwohl sie nach ihrer klage eigentlich
verfallen sollten und als
gegenfinanzierung für anträge nutzen sie
müssen sich schon entscheiden was sie
konkret wollen das ist
haushaltstechnisch und rechtlich nicht
möglich um ihre klage in karlsruhe haben
damit ad absurdum geführt
kollege meyer des angesprochenen kollege
roger ist angesprochen wir müssen diesem
haushalt die notfall rick der
schuldenbremse ziehen weil wir immer
noch die folgen der korona pandemie
sehen und weil wir auch zusätzlich jetzt
mit dem schrecklichen krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine eine neue notlage
haben die große soziale ökonomische und
humanitäre herausforderung mit sich
bringt und deswegen ist es richtig dass
wir jetzt hier konkret auf diese krisen
reagieren und aktiv an in der krise wir
sagen sehr klar mit diesem hause wir
sparen uns sind keine krisen hinein
und nicht wünsche mir und
ich wünsche mir sehr wirklich sehr dass
wir sehr schnell aus diesen krisen
wieder herauskommen so war das wirklich
schrecklich ist was wir gerade
tagtäglich sehen und viele menschen auch
weltweit besonders ukraine gerade
erleben müssen aber ich habe nicht die
hoffnung und ich habe die befürchtung
dass das nicht so schnell leider enden
wird wenn ich mir das handeln und die
schrecklichen pläne und wladimir putin
anschaue wenn ich mir die großen
internationalen folgen anschauen die
großen sozialen ökonomischen folgen wie
es wird deutsch in europa hat anschaue
dann habe ich die große sorge dass das
nicht 2022 schon zu ende ist und dieser
konflikt ist kein 100 meter lauf sondern
das ist ein marathon und zentral ist
dass europa diesen zeiten fest und
geeint zusammensteht und sich nicht nur
wladimir putin auf der strecke dann
auseinander dividieren lässt
und
dies
muss sich dann auch die finanzpolitik
mit ihrer dienen funktion auch
unterordnen deswegen ist es richtig dass
die europäische kommission jetzt zu 2023
die ausnahmeklausel stabilitäts und
wachstumspakt noch mal beschlossen hat
europa hat aus den fehlern der letzten
finanzkrise um den fehlern der austritts
politik geladen in zeitnot handelt man
spart sich in keine krisen hinein
und deswegen bin ich auch noch mal klar
sagen deutschland hat als größte
volkswirtschaft europas eine besondere
verantwortung diesen zeiten und es geht
auch für die aufstellung des
bundeshaushalts
23 gerade wenn eine notlage besteht kann
man eben nicht den rotstift ansetzen an
normalität suggerierenden da muss man
aktiv handeln das notwendig auch
finanzieren
wir haben diesen rauszufahren 22 gezeigt
wir sorgen aktiv für die zukunft vor wir
reagieren aktiv auf krisen wir haben
viel bewegt im haushaltsverfahren wir
haben die regierung dort unterstützt wo
es notwendig war wir haben sie auch dort
als selbstbewusst parlament korrigiert
und ergänzt wo es notwendig war starke
für die zusammenarbeit und den für die
zustimmung zum haushalt dank sven
christian kindler war das ja
haushaltspolitische sprecher der
die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen hat
sich geäußert unter anderem auch zum
kompromiss der ampel mit der union beim
sonder etat für die bundeswehr wo der
bereich der cyber sicherheit ja erst mal
ausgeklammert worden ist der nächste
redner florian oßner aus der
unionsfraktion beziehungsweise aus der
csu-landesgruppe und nach ihm kommt der
bundesfinanzminister
das gleicht schon echt einem sehr teuren
wunschkonzert was hier die ampel
regierung als haushalt für das jahr 2022
vorgelegt hat alle vorlieben der
koalitionäre werden da gleichermaßen
bedient für die grünen ein bisschen
klima für die fdp ein bisschen politik
marketing und wie die spd ein bisschen
soziales leider läuft dieses konzert
unter dem titel wer wacht die meisten
schulden waren grüne und fdp in der
vergangenheit immer gegen
schattenhaushalte wollten subventionen
streichen und den solidaritätszuschlag
komplett abschaffen so bleiben davon nur
noch leere worthülsen wirklich sehr sehr
schade die liebe am koalitionäre so
schafft man definitiv kein vertrauen in
die finanzpolitik in deutschland
es ist absehbar und die glaskugel das
auch bei uns die leitzinsen steigen wir
haben bereits eine rekord inflation und
damit wird auch das massive schulden
machen des bundes immer teurer also was
würde der vernünftige und vorsichtige
kaufmann machen richtig sich beschränken
prioritäten setzen ausgabenprogramme
überprüfen und gegebenenfalls auch den
ihr streichen stattdessen bekommen wir
einen eine nettoneuverschuldung von rund
140 milliarden euro präsentiert dann
kommen noch durch buchungstricks weitere
60 milliarden euro kredite dazu
natürlich dass schulden finanziert die
sondervermögen bundeswehr in höhe von
100 milliarden euro sage und schreibe in
summe 300 milliarden euro neue schulden
und bei den parlamentarischen beratungen
wurden nochmals 11,9 milliarden euro
draufgesattelt damit lädt sich der
bundeshaushalt auf annähernd eine halbe
million euro auf das ist wirklich
wahnsinn und an verantwortungslosigkeit
in der tat nicht mehr zu überbieten
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen ampel
spare in der zeit dann hast du in der
not wir kennen alle diese alte weisheit
ohne das konsequente einhalten der
ausgeglichenen haushalte seit 2014 durch
unions geführte bundesregierungen hätten
wir die wirtschaftlichen folgen der
pandemie und jetzt des ukraine tricks
nicht abfedern können die ampel scheint
hingegen bei jedem problem in den
finanzpolitischen amoklauf zu verfallen
hier ein paar milliarden da ein paar
milliarden ist wird nur noch in
milliarden einheiten gesprochen ohne
jeglicher
gegenfinanzierung die enden sie deshalb
bitte sofort diese sinnlose
verfrühstücken der zukunft unserer
nachfolgenden generationen
dass das wort zurückhaltung scheint
zudem für die ampel nicht im wortschatz
vorhanden zu sein das gilt insbesondere
dann wenn es um die vergabe von posten
geht insgesamt fast
10.000 zusätzliche stellen auch das
problem der ausgabereste in den
ministerien wird von der koalition
komplett ausgeblendet uni gehört knapp
20 milliarden euro haushalts transparenz
sieht wahrlich anders aus liebe
ampelkoalition ehre
als union fordern wir deshalb die
bundesregierung auch in unserem
entschließungsantrag auch senken sie die
neuverschuldung um über 100 milliarden
euro durch die auflösung der rücklagen
und durch die nichtinanspruchnahme der
korona beziehungsweise klima kredite
entlasten sie die bürgerinnen und bürger
sowie die unternehmen durch die
beseitigung der kalten progression
im steuertarif und schaffen sie endlich
den der solidaritätszuschlag komplett ab
und nehmen sie die personal währung
zurück welche sowieso am ende nur mehr
bürokratie schafft herzliches vergelt's
gott verstören florian oßner aus der
unionsfraktion spricht von 300
milliarden neuen schulden die die ampel
koalition mache das ist nur bedingt
richtig der energie 100 milliarden für
den für das sondervermögen bundeswehr
mal mit eingerechnet das sind aber
bislang nur kreditermächtigungen und
wann die wirksam werden wird sich weisen
christian lindner
sie haben vorgeschlagen dass sie die
rücklagen auflösen wollen die in ihrer
eigenen früheren mittelfristigen
finanzplanung noch benötigt worden ist
um im nächsten jahr die schuldenbremse
des grundgesetzes einzuhalten das ist
leider widersprüchlich der wechsel von
regierung die opposition ist eben nicht
gut bekommen
ich will mich aber mit dank für die
große einigkeit beim
sondervermögen von diesem sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr geht eine doppelte
botschaft aus wir stärken mit 100
milliarden euro investitionen unsere
fähigkeit zur landes- und
bündnisverteidigung
aber wir tun dies parallel zur
schuldenbremse des grundgesetzes
die schuldenbremse selbst bleibt für
alle anderen aufgaben und vorhaben
erhalten das ist die doppelte botschaft
wir antworten auf die
sicherheitspolitische zeitenwende mit
der stärkung der streitkräfte wir
antworten auf die ökonomische
zeitenwende der inflation durch die
rückkehr zu soliden haushalten und das
ende immer neuer schulden
damit folgen wir auch dem rat der
europäischen kommission wenn die
europäische kommission hat ja bei ihrem
finanzpolitischen ausblick zwar die
allgemeine ausweis klausel verlängert
zugleich hat sie aber nicht empfohlen
davon gebrauch zu machen im gegenteil
sie hat gesagt wir müssen zu
fiskalischer neutralität also nicht
durch immer neue subventionen und
ausgabenprogramme die inflationären und
genau das muss unser ziel sein rückkehr
zur schuldenbremse bedeutet druck von
den preisen nehmen indem wir nicht immer
mehr umverteilen und immer mehr
subventionen erfinden
herr kollege mittelberg im zweiten
regierungsentwurf
2022 haben wir genau ihre zahl von 99,7
milliarden euro nettokreditaufnahme
eingehalten wir haben nicht mehr
schulden gemacht als sie in ihrer
regierungszeit vor hatten aber wir haben
mit ihren eckpunkten anderes gemacht
mehr für bildung soziale aufgaben
investitionen und entlastung das zeigt
bereits mit dem zweiten
regierungsentwurf hat die andere mit der
konsolidierung begonnen aber
neue aufgaben kamen hinzu
neue aufgaben kamen hinzu und deshalb
haben wir einen ergänzungs haushalt
bekanntlich vorgelegt weil dinge nicht
vorhersehbar war ich länger als ein
beispiel tennis ohne darauf eingegangen
eine milliarde euro zuschuss um die
liquidität der ukraine zu erhalten damit
sie ihre starts funktionen garantieren
kann das zeigt die ampel koalition nimmt
internationale verantwortung wahr ohne
den ergänzungs haushalt und ohne die
klaren entscheidungen des
haushaltsausschusses wäre nicht
gesichert dass die ukraine ihr recht auf
selbstverteidigung verwirklichen kann
und geben mehr einnahmen die der staat
in diesem jahr erzielt kollege
mittelberg die gibt er zurück wir haben
ein entlastungspaket bzw mehrere
entlastungspaket mit in der summe über
30 milliarden euro geschnürt das was uns
an mehreinnahmen
zufließt das geht an die bürgerinnen und
bürger zurück auch dadurch indem ihr den
von der cdu csu für das jahr 2022
beschlossen steuertarif rückwirkend zum
ersten januar mit
arbeitnehmerpauschbetrag und höheren
grundfreibetrag korrigieren das war ihr
erbe dieser steuertarif und der beide
kommen neue maßnahmen hinzu zum beispiel
eine befristete senkung der
energiesteuern am morgigen tag gilt die
sie wird nicht sofort wirksam seien aus
technischen gründen es ist kein
geheimnis ich hätte ein anderes modell
vorgezogen ich hätte wie in italien ich
hätte die in italien eine beihilfe
empfohlen wo man direkte vorgaben an die
mineralölgesellschaften machen kann das
wäre mein modell gewesen wir haben uns
dann im politischen diskurs entschieden
für eine steuersenkung diese
steuersenkung muss aber jetzt
durchgesetzt werden das ist jetzt eine
aufgabe des kartellamts wir müssen
sicherstellen dass die steuersenkung bei
den autofahrerinnen und bei den pendlern
ankommt denn für die ist das gemeint
nicht für die mineralölgesellschaften
feuer auch ihr modell die steuern zu
senken sie wollten ja sogar noch die
mehrwertsteuer senken was aus
europäischen rechts gründen ohne
weiteres nicht möglich gewesen wäre und
letzter punkt zu den stellen wir reden
hier über den einzelplan 8 hat bisher
noch niemand getan deshalb will ich
smava weil sie auch kritik von der cdu
csu kam im einzelplan acht schaffe ich
1000 oder schlage ich vor und der
haushalts wird ja von ihnen
beschlossenen schlage ich vor 1400
zusätzliche stellen zu schaffen für
zöllnerinnen und zöllner
das ist eine investition
kommt
der mittelwert räumen sie das nicht will
die cdu csu das nicht 1400 zöllnerinnen
und zöllner ist eine investition in die
wettbewerbsfähigkeit eines exportlandes
damit das schnell abgewickelt werden
kann es ist zugleich aber auch eine
investition in die bekämpfung von
finanzkriminalität geldwäsche und
schwarzarbeit wurden sie das nicht wir
wollen gas
wir wollen das denn unser ziel ist es
die ehrlichen steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler vor mehrbelastungen zu
schützen indem wir die schwarzen schafe
dingfest machen und dafür sorgen dass
sie ihren fairen beitrag zur
finanzierung des gemeinwesens leisten
christian gentner der
bundesfinanzminister unter anderem zum
diesen tagen viel diskutierten
sogenannten tank rabatt morgen beginnt
die stunde der wahrheit wirklich mehr
wissen wir dann wahrscheinlich in 34
tagen hier geht's weiter mit harald weil
aus der fdp fraktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin damen und herren und
liebes finanzpolitik geplantes publikum
alle behalten ich frage mich ob er hat
recht nicht mit blick auf den deutschen
finanzminister auf die europäische union
und auch die zentralbank sein zitat
variieren würde bankraub ist eine
unternehmung von dilettanten wahre
profis gründen eine bank und noch wahre
profis kunden eine europäische bank
zentralbank und die ganz ganz waren
profis die machen mehrheitlich ein
bundeshaushalt
seit über einem jahrzehnt kann man das
untersuchungs projekttitel ist nicht von
mir deutschland zahlmeister der eu von
professor emeritus franz ulrich villiger
uni heidelberg fortschreiben mit diesen
sowie eigenen recherchen kann man
folgende feststellungen treffen erstens
kann wohl nicht bezweifelt werden dass
eine laufende umverteilung zwischen
verschiedenen mitgliedstaaten ein
wesentliches merkmal der eu ist die eu
samt vorläufern stellt somit schon lange
eine transfer union dar
zweitens die europäische kommission hat
erstmalig so viel zeit hatte man 2006
rückwirkend für die jahre ab 76 daten zu
den einnahmen und ausgaben der eu
veröffentlicht die erlauben das erstmals
aussagen über die nettobeiträge und
netto leistungen zu machen und man kann
konstatieren schon in den 15 jahren vor
der wiedervereinigung zahlte deutschland
60 prozent aller nettoleistung
drittens in den ersten 20 jahren der
wiedervereinigung 1 9 2011 zahlte
deutschland fast 250 milliarden als
gesamt belasten des haushalts an die eu
vorletztes jahr lagen hier bei circa 20
milliarden netto und jetzt geht sogar
mit 30 milliarden weiter jährlich
weitere eu eigenmittel zöller abgabe
kommen hinzu und weitere werden erfunden
zitierte eine zusätzliche quelle
deutschland zahlt auch innerhalb der
nettozahler 61 milliarden mehr als ein
angemessener nettobeitrag gewesen wären
deutschland wurde regelrecht
ausgeplündert so der wissenschaftler
willige zitat ende
eben war noch die rede von 60 milliarden
die fehlten sind also schon längst
woanders hingegangen unterm strich gilt
deutschland gesamt beitrag zu der eu
beträgt zwischen 40 und 50 prozent und
das vor dem hintergrund dass der
deutsche anteil am
sozialprodukt des brüsseler eu europas
niemals mehr als ein viertel von dessen
sozialprodukt und bevölkerung ausgemacht
hat ich komme zum schluss jährlich zig
milliarden zahlung aus dem
bundeshaushalt wachsen seit dem dritten
abgangs sprungartig an und all die
zusätzlichen fonds und haftungsrisiken
die quasi gratis kredite ohne
sicherheiten haben die billionengrenze
längst überschritten sie stellen immer
mehr eine bloße wechsel reiterei und
konkursverschleppung dar die
gegenleistung dafür erinnert bestenfalls
an eine leistungsschwache wenn ich gab
betrügerische
versicherungsgesellschaft deren prämien
ständig steigen und wurde er immer
teurer bezahlte versicherungsfall oder
leistungsfall stets weg geleugnet oder
umgangen wird sehr effektive außen
grenzsicherung sowie vertragstreue und
rechtssicherheit und bürgerliche
freiheitsrechte mit und ohne corona das
ist insbesondere für deutschland eher
ein einziges angebot zur ausbeutung
stadt wohlstandsmehrung bereit mit dem
am ende konstruktiv rät willeke 0,2
prozent des bruttonationaleinkommens
reichen auf deutsch übersetzt und hier
und jetzt die hälfte der überweisungen
reicht aus und es können sogar noch die
gleichen nettoleistung an die
nettoempfänger ausgezahlt werden
halbieren sie diese kosten dann haben
wir 20 milliarden zusätzlich zur
verfügung dankeschön
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die spd fraktion dr
thorsten rudolph
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte präsidentin sehr geehrter
herr minister liebe kollegin den
prognosen sind schwierig sagt ein bon ho
besonders wenn sie die zukunft betreffen
das gilt in normalen zeiten
aber die zeiten sind nicht normal
wie schlimm wird die nächste corona
welle wie geht es mit dem ukraine krieg
weiter wie mit den locker und sind china
und den schiffen vor shanghai was heißt
das alles für die lieferketten und die
versorgung der welt mit lebensmitteln
und rohstoffen wie geht es mit der
inflation weiter und so weiter und so
fort sicher ist aktuell nur dass nichts
sicher ist deshalb war es der ampel
koalition so wichtig mit diesem haushalt
2022 stabilität zu gewährleisten und
gestaltungsspielraum zu bewahren mit
weiterhin umfassenden kroner hilfen mit
den beiden entlastungs paketen für die
bürger innen in höhe von insgesamt 30
milliarden euro mit rekord investitionen
in klima wenn die digitalisierung
bildung verkehr und sozialen wohnungsbau
sven christian kindler als eben
ausgeführt und natürlich mit
zusätzlicher finanzieller hilfe für die
ukraine mit unterstützung für die
geflüchteten mit mehr humanitäre hilfe
und mit mitteln für unsere am stärksten
vom krieg betroffenen unternehmen allein
diese zusätzlichen mittel wegen des
krieges schlagen mit knapp 40 milliarden
euro zu buche ansonsten aber entspricht
die verschuldung mit 99 7 milliarden
euro dem was schon die große koalition
im ersten regierungsentwurf vorgesehen
hatte nicht schön aber eben das ergebnis
der außergewöhnlichen notsituationen im
sinne von artikel 115 grundgesetz in der
wir uns eben befinden und die dieses
hohe haus zu recht festgestellt hat
gerade weil diese auszeiten maß und
mitte heldt ist es ein kluger haushalt
meine damen und herren die auf die
herausforderungen reagiert aber eben
zugleich spielräume lässt dieser
haushalt meine damen und herren ist
finanziell verantwortungsvoll und stock
soliden
cdu und csu und ihren vertretern ist das
nicht genug habe ich gelesen fordern
massive mehrausgaben wollen die
mehrwertsteuer senken auf strom gas und
fernwärme die netzentgelte senken die
kalte progression ausgleichen
garantierte zinsen bei der
altersvorsorge zahlen die grenzwerte
beim arbeitnehmer sparbetrag bei der
arbeitnehmer sparzulage verdoppeln den
sparerpauschbetrag verdoppeln den
erstmaligen erwerb selbstgenutzter
immobilien fördern eine
sonderabschreibung für energieeffiziente
wohngebäude einführen den
verteidigungshaushalt kontinuierliche
aufwachsen lassen und nicht zu vergessen
natürlich den solidaritätszuschlag für
die oberen zehn prozent
abschaffen allein diese letzte maßnahme
kostet 11 milliarden euro und das jahr
für jahr ich bin beeindruckt der kollege
mittelberg wie sie auf der ausgabenseite
arbeiten alles in allem meine damen und
herren wird das eine regelrechte
schuldenorgie was sie vorschlagen
und liebe kolleginnen das sind nur die
ausgabenwünsche der letzten zwei drei
monate ohne jeden anspruch auf
vollständigkeit ich habe einfach schnell
wieder aufgehört zu recherchieren weil
ich angst hatte meine ganze redezeit für
zusatzaufgaben der union auf draufgeht
das beste daran ist aber die union
beklagt zugleich ständig dass die ampel
angeblich rekordschulden machen also die
schulden die die cdu/csu selbst in der
großen koalition beschlossen hat und die
knapp 40 milliarden zusätzlich für die
ukraine die im großen und ganzen
unstrittig sind muss sagen ich habe
schon einen gewissen respekt vor so viel
unverfrorenheit cdu/csu greifen verbal
ungeniert in den staatssäckel rufen
dabei zugleich haltet den dieb
sehr verehrten damen und herren ich will
nicht unterschlagen dass die union auch
einmal beträge sparen bilden
beispielsweise die zweieinhalb
milliarden euro für das neue euro ticket
750 millionen bei der dekarbonisierung
der wirtschaft 50 millionen bei der
querschnittsaufgabe energieeffizienz und
natürlich die 60 milliarden euro für den
energie und klimafonds ist ein christian
kindler hat alles dazu gesagt alle diese
vorschläge zusammen ergeben ein präzises
bild welche politik die union will
entlastungen für wohlhabende weniger
geld für die verkehrswende viel weniger
geld für die klimawende dafür aber wie
ich lese gerne atomkraft und viele
erkennen hier schon deutlich die
handschrift von friedrich merz fest
steht jedenfalls kolleginnen und
kollegen das ist politik für die 80er
jahre nicht für die 2020 erwarten
damen und herren die ampel macht politik
für die 2020er jahre zum glück auch wenn
die bedingungen zur zeit alles andere
als einfach sind sie haben
wahrscheinlich gestern auch alle gelesen
dass eine ifo studie noch in diesem jahr
einen preisanstieg bei den lebensmitteln
um weitere zehn prozent erwartet und wir
wissen alle dass steigende
lebensmittelpreise und energiepreise
gerade menschen mit geringem einkommen
besonders hart treffen lassen sie es
mich der daher hier von diesem pult aus
ganz deutlich sagen wir lassen niemanden
im stich wir beobachten die lage sehr
genau und werden gegebenenfalls
reagieren und weitere entlastung
beschließen diese koalition hat gezeigt
dass sie auch kurzfristig handlungsfähig
ist
meine damen und herren wir wissen alle
nicht wie es weitergeht mit krieg
pandemie und inflation eines wissen wir
aber jetzt schon wir wissen dass die
energiepreise dauerhaft hoch bleiben
werden die zeiten billigen gases aus
russland sind vorbei die energiewende
kommt mit einem schnellen ausbau der
erneuerbaren energien einer konsequenten
co2 bepreisung und wir wissen auch und
zwar jetzt schon dass die energiewende
nur dann ein erfolg wird wenn sie kein
eliten projekt bleibt deshalb finde ich
den vorschlag von lukas heil ein sozial
gestaffeltes klima geld einzuführen auch
so gut und so wichtig wir brauchen eine
dauerhafte und gezielte entlastung bei
den energiepreisen für alle mit geringen
und mittleren einkommen diejenigen die
es am nötigsten brauchen sollen am
meisten bekommen dies nicht ganz so
nötig haben bekommen etwas und die viel
verdienen bekommen nichts den augen
gekehrt verhält es sich übrigens wenn
wir stattdessen die einkommenssteuer
senken denn die geringverdiener zahlen
keine einkommenssteuer und bekommen dann
nichts die wenig verdienen bekommen
etwas und die vielverdiener bekommen am
meisten deshalb kolleginnen kollegen bin
ich froh dass das klima geld im
koalitionsvertrag steht steuersenkungen
aber nicht
meine damen und herren wir haben in
frankreich gesehen wo marine le pen die
lebenshaltungskosten gezielt
instrumentalisiert hat wohin das führt
und das sollte auch uns in deutschland
klar sein eine klima wende ohne sozialen
ausgleich wird es nicht geben
klimawandel ist keine aufgabe für ein
oder zwei legislaturperioden und wer
dauerhaft eine politische mehrheit für
eine wirkliche klimawende wer die
gesellschaft zusammenhalten will bei der
großen transformation der muss die
menschen mitnehmen das ist die aufgabe
kolleginnen und kollegen ich verspreche
ihnen die spd fraktion wird alles dafür
tun diese aufgabe zu erfüllen herz
gegangen
thorsten rudolph für die spd fraktion in
dieser debatte des deutschen bundestages
sie die haushaltswoche eröffnet das geht
im großen und ganzen um die
finanzpolitik eben allgemeinen aber ganz
nebenbei in anführungszeichen auch um
den etat des bundesfinanzministers
nächster redner ist christian görke aus
der linksfraktion wo ihr
finanzpolitischer sprecher ist und er
war von 14 bis 19 finanzminister in
brandenburg der koalition ist eine
einzige fingerhakeleien und er ist auch
unehrlich 100 milliarden sondervermögen
für die bundeswehr 40 milliarden euro
ergänzungs haushalt alles an der
schuldenbremse vorbei getrickst und wenn
sie schon meine damen und herren von der
koalition mit der cdu an das grundgesetz
gehen um ihren aufrüstung waren
abzusichern dann haben sie die mut diese
schuldenbremse zu reformieren und zwar
mit einer goldenen regel dass auch in
zukunft noch investitionen in
klimaschutz und vor allen dingen auch in
die verkehrswende enke gerecht
realisiert werden könnten und sehr
geehrter herr bundes ganz minister
interessant war ja eben ihre these dass
die rückkehr zur schuldenbremse und eine
sparpolitik die inflation senden wird
dabei ist die sparpolitik der
vergangenheit eine ursache für diese
inflation dass wir so abhängig sind
calling von diesen energieimporten dass
wir bei den erneuerbaren und auch bei
der verkehrs länder längst nicht da sind
wo wir sein müssten und außerdem der
finanzministerien sie hören mal von
wachstum wo soll er denn herkommen solle
vom himmel fallen wenn sie nächstes jahr
die schuldenbremse einführen
ziehen sie die handbremse an dieser
konjunktur und die logik ist ganz
einfach wenn sie ab 20 23
132 milliarden euro weniger ausgeben
dann heißt das
132 milliarden weniger für investitionen
132 milliarden einnahmen weniger in den
wirtschaftskreislauf und zuzüglich die
abrissbirne an den sozialstaat sofern
sie nicht endlich um steuern und vor
allen dingen diese exorbitanten und die
zahlen recht über einiger weniger in
deutschland endlich enkel gerecht
besteuern und meine damen und herren
unsere vorschläge für eine
vermögensabgabe zur verbesserung der
einnahmen der bundeshaushalt liegen auf
dem tisch die gewerkschaften und
begrüßen dass und deshalb meine damen
und herren von spd und grüne machen sie
sich endlich ehrlich und steuern sie im
wahrsten sinne des wortes um und lassen
sie sich nicht weiter von diesem
finanzminister mit dem nasenring
gerüchten steuerpolitischer manege
ziehen ihr und sehr geehrter herr
kindler sie haben zu recht gesagt da
muss ich mal korrigieren deshalb noch
einmal ein dringender appell an die
ampeln korrigieren sie ihre unsägliche
entscheidung zur energieforschung
denn es ist unakzeptabel dass sogar
jetzt der kanzler und die mitglieder
dieser bundesregierung diese pauschale
bekommen und die rentnerinnen und
rentner und die studenten wie bekannt
leer ausgehen dass korrigieren sie das
vielen dank
christian görke für die linksfraktion
und ihm wird jetzt folgen
christian
stimmt gar nicht der nächste redner ist
nämlich andreas tracz für die fraktion
bündnis 90/die grünen wo er seit kurzem
auch stellvertretender
fraktionsvorsitzender ist in der
nachfolge von dieter paus die jetzt
ministerin ist sehr geehrte damen und
herren
als wir unseren koalitionsvertrag mit
der überschrift mehr fortschritt wagen
überschrieben haben da wussten wir dass
wir für fortschritt investieren müssen
und genau das tun wir jetzt mit diesem
haushalt
2022 wir starten eine
investitionsoffensive zb mit den 60
milliarden zusätzlich im klima- und
transformations- vor auch die humanitäre
hilfe liegt mit 2,7 milliarden euro auf
rekordniveau und für den sozialen
frieden in deutschland bringen wir
angesichts von 7,9 prozent fossile
inflation mehr als 40 milliarden euro in
den entlastungs paketen auf
das ist gut und das ist richtig
investiertes geld jeder euro den wir
heute in den ausbau erneuerbarer
energien stecken
der wird uns frei machen und er wird uns
unabhängig machen von diktatoren wie
wladimir putin die mit der
preistreiberei politik machen und wir
dürfen uns keiner illusion hingeben im
moment nutzt putin korn und getreide als
warf er wird im herbst auch gas als
waffe nutzen und deswegen müssen wir
auch an der stelle investieren um
wegzukommen von infizierten systemen wir
müssen jeden euro in klimaschutz
investieren weil wir damit katastrophen
wie im aartal verhindern milliarden über
milliarden kostet das jetzt aufzuräumen
wenn wir investieren dann haben wir die
andere logik nicht klimaschutz zu
betreiben ist das teuerste was wir tun
können das dürfen wir können generation
ist nicht aufbürden deswegen müssen wir
jetzt investieren und die 100 milliarden
euro für die bundeswehr die sind gut für
die verteidigungsfähigkeit deswegen
werde ich am freitag zustimmen aber sie
sind angesichts der klimakatastrophe und
angesichts der sozialen fragen keine
ausreichende antwort auf die größte
herausforderung die wir in diesem land
haben das den übrigens nicht nur wir so
da sieht auch die europäische kommission
so deswegen hat sie beschlossen auch
2023 die schuldenregeln noch einmal
ausgesetzt zu lassen weil es um
verantwortung geht in einer
krisensituation weil es um verantwortung
geht die größer ist als die
schuldenbremse weil es im verantwortung
geht die größer ist als die ideologie
einer schwarzen null eine verantwortung
der wir uns auch hier in deutschland
stellen werden
und das gilt auch für die steuerpolitik
lassen sie uns darüber reden herr
lindner dass wir kleine und mittlere
einkommen in der einkommensteuer
entlasten das können wir gerne machen
aber völlig klar ist doch dabei auch
dass wir gleichzeitig auch darüber reden
müssen den spitzensteuersatz dann
anzuheben nur das macht sind nur das
denn nur dann können wir gemeinsam über
eine reform an der stelle reden mehr
investieren gleichzeitig mindereinnahmen
in kauf zu nehmen und gleichzeitig keine
schulden zu machen das zusammen
funktioniert nicht das passt nicht
zusammen schon rechnerisch nicht
deswegen ist es aufgabe
deswegen ist es aufgabe für den haushalt
2023 und die beratungen das stimmig zu
machen genau das ist aufgabe der
verhandlungen 23 und dieser
verantwortung werden wir uns als ampel
angesichts der großen krisen und
herausforderungen dieser zeit stellen
herzlichen dank
nächster redner für die cdu csu fraktion
dr carsten bresser
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen in diesem monat veröffentlichte
das bundesfinanzministerium ein
bemerkenswertes strategie papier unter
dem titel finanzpolitik in der
zeitenwende wachstum stärken und
inflationäre impulse vermeiden dort
heißt es unter anderem es brauche eine
finanzpolitik die effizient und
vorausschauend agiert effizient bedeute
nach ihrer auffassung ausgaben
fortlaufend zu priorisieren und zu
evaluieren
sie herr lindner fordern ferner
finanzpolitische verlässlichkeit und die
schnelle wiedereinführung der
schuldenbremse und sie wollen
öffentliche investitionen gegenüber
zusätzlichen sozialausgaben priorisieren
das alles sind beeindruckende aussagen
die auch aus der feder von ludwig erhard
stammen könnten doch die von ihnen
genannten ansprüche entsprechend leider
nicht der finanzpolitischen realität
ihre bekenntnisse sowie der einführung
der schuldenbremse suggerieren der
bundeshaushalt sei ein hort der
stabilität doch das gegenteil ist der
fall noch nie in der geschichte unseres
landes war die bundesrepublik so hoch
verschuldet wie heute und sie wollen
diese schulden noch mal um 139
milliarden euro erhöhen wer im sinne von
prioritätensetzung nach einsparung sucht
sucht leider vergebens anstatt den
beamtenapparat des gesamten bundes
abzuspecken schaffen sie 9600
zusätzliche stellen ihre ausgabenplanung
beläuft sich mittlerweile auf sage und
schreibe 4 196 milliarden euro jeden
vierten ausgegebenen euro finanzieren
sie durch neue schulden die
gesamtwirtschaftliche verschuldung die
gesamtstaatliche verschuldung steigt
damit auf 2,4 billionen euro das sind
29.000 euro pro bundesbürger vom kind
bis zur rentnerin pro sekunde erhöht
sich der schuldenstand um weitere 4900
euro
länder sie bekennen sich zu schnellen
wie der einführung der schuldenbremse
das ist gut aber in wahrheit war bereits
im nachtragshaushalt 20 21 der anfang
vom ende der schuldenbremse in den
jahren 2020 bis 2022 wird allein der
bund 485 milliarden neue schulden
gemacht haben denn dazu ursprünglich ab
2023 beginnenden tilgungsplan haben sie
kurzerhand auf 2.028 verschoben die
türken auch nicht mehr innerhalb von 20
jahren wie es ursprünglich beschlossen
wurde sondern sie strecken die
rückzahlung auf 30 jahren schieben das
bis auf das jahr 2058 hinaus gegenüber
unseren kindern und enkeln ist eine
solche finanzpolitik weder nachhaltig
noch sozial denn nicht unsere generation
doch diese schon zurückzahlen sondern
die kommende generation durch die
hauptlasten tragen muss herr
finanzminister die politischen und
finanziellen gestaltungsmöglichkeiten
generation zukünftiger generationen
schwinden damit immer weiter wenn sie
nicht schleunigst eine schubumkehr
einleiten umso bemerkenswerter ist es
dass sie in ihrem papier selbst zu der
erkenntnis kommen dass man in ökonomisch
unsicheren zeiten keine
sozialpolitischen leistungen erhöhen
sollte aber genau das bereiten sie
gerade vor sie entwickeln ein bürgergeld
das den bundeshaushalt noch mal
milliarden kosten wird und auf dem weg
dorthin schaffen sie mal eben sämtliche
sanktionen ab die bisher zur
leistungskürzung aufgrund der verletzung
von mitwirkungspflichten führen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen der
sozialleistungen beziehen für den gibt
es auch die verpflichtung zur mitwirkung
diese ist unverzichtbar denn solidarität
ist keine einbahnstraße
der sozialstaat wird von den menschen
getragen die jeden tag zur arbeit gehen
die länder wollen den prinzipien der
haushaltswahrheit und ausland
transferiert wieder stärker geltung
verschaffen das unterstützen wir
ausdrücklich
gleichzeitig erkennen sie dass der
demografische wandel die
sozialversicherungssysteme zunehmend
unter druck setzt liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen der steuerzuschuss zur
gesetzlichen rentenversicherung reiche
in diesem jahr bereits einen wert von
über 100 milliarden wollen die
gesetzliche kranken- und
pflegeversicherung benötigen ebenfalls
zuschüsse aus dem bundeshaushalt sie
herr lindner erkennen selbst dass das
demographische risiko den
handlungsspielraum des bundeshaushalts
weiter einschränkte welt aber die
implizite deckung der verbindlichkeiten
der sozialversicherung ist eine
schwebende schuld in unserem haushalt
die jetzt angegangen werden muss anstatt
zügig über notwendige reformen zu
entscheiden planen sie den einstieg in
eine kapitalgedeckte säule zur
stabilisierung der gesetzlichen
rentenversicherung gut zehn milliarden
euro sollten dafür im aktuellen haushalt
eigentlich bereitgestellt werden bei
einer angenommenen verzinsung von
beispielsweise sechs prozent würde
dieser fonds also 600 millionen euro per
anno wirtschaften viel geld glaubt man
aber das entspreche lediglich 0,2
prozent der beitragseinnahmen des
letzten jahres eine begrüßenswerte aber
leider nur homöopathische entlastung und
weit entfernt von einem notwendigen
reformpaket doch selbst dieses minimal
vor haben sucht man die im aktuellen
haushalt leider vergebens serie der
bundesfinanzminister auch die
finanzpolitik ist in einer zeitenwende
deswegen brauchen wir jetzt geeignete
und mutige entscheidung mit
entsprechender größe wenn sie als
ampelkoalition wachstum stärken
inflationäre impulse vermeiden und die
sozialversicherungssysteme stabilisieren
wollen dann müssen sie ihre selbst
formulierten ansprüche auch den
realitäten vielen dank
carsten roth ist für die unionsfraktion
die ja der meinung ist dass es so viele
schulden nicht gebraucht hätte für oder
viele neue schulden für diesen
bundeshaushalt wenn man beispielsweise
auf die eine oder andere rücklage
verzichtet beziehungsweise sie aufgelöst
hätte otto fricke ist der nächste redner
der haushaltspolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion
kurz fest zweiten was diese
koalitionsgespräche im thema haushalt in
die verhandlungen im haushaltsausschuss
ausgemacht haben ist eigentlich fast
unmöglich dennoch will ich mal eine
sache für diese koalition voranstellen
ein haushalt ist nichts anderes als der
inbegriff des kompromisses denen eine
koalition treffen muss da findet sich
jeder aber jeder auch nicht und ich
möchte mich ausdrücklich bei den beiden
koalitionspartnern bedanken mit ihren
arbeitsgruppen dass wir diesen haushalt
so hinbekommen haben wie wir in diesen
schwierigen zeiten auch ihm bekommen
musste meine damen und herren wir haben
dabei auch die parlamentsrechte gestärkt
ich komme gleich noch dazu zu der frage
anträge aber wir haben auch dafür
gesorgt dass sie nicht mitbekommen haben
dass wir selbst bei der frage des
beschaffungswesens schon eine erste
gesetzliche regelung vorgenommen haben
die dafür sorgt dass der
haushaltsausschuss und damit das
parlament bei der frage wer beschaffung
im militärwesen zukünftig an der
explizit starke rolle spielen wird wir
werden das wahrscheinlich am freitag
noch einmal verstärken dafür großer dank
denn es ist am ende wichtig dass beim
thema haushalt klar ist dass die
bundesregierung nur das machen kann was
das parlament als erste gewalt ihr auch
sagt dass es zu tun hat beziehungsweise
dass sie es tun kann das wiederum meine
damen und herren
habe ich so das gefühl
ist etwas was in den nächsten jahren auf
uns noch ein weiterer arbeit zukommen
wird denn wir müssen erkennen wir können
nicht einfach immer nur leistungsgesetze
ausbauen wir müssen auch immer noch in
der gesamtwürdigung sehen dass diese
leistungsgesetze an die jeweiligen
realitäten sich anpassen das heißt dann
nicht weil fdp das sagt es geht um
kürzungen sondern heißt dann genau dass
man gucken muss es notwendig es ist
angesprochen worden und ich sage das
auch jetzt schon in richtung cdu csu wir
haben eine sozialleistung ausdrücklich
gestärkt die künstlersozialkasse und
zwar deswegen weil wir erkannt haben
dass wir hier den schwächsten helfen
müssen und dass ihr andere
voraussetzungen in der krise in der
korona krise galten als sie vorher warnt
abgelehnt worden ist diese erhöhung von
einer fraktion von der cdu/csu das ist
das wo ich dann immer sagen da zeigt
sich wie diese ampel wird man macht
kompromisse man stärkt den sozialen
bereich aber man weiß auch wo die
grenzen sind und herr milberg der
minister hat das schon zu den ställen
und im zoll gesagt die sie nicht haben
wollen es ist schon gesagt worden zu den
ställen beim bundeskriminalamt die sie
nicht haben wollen jetzt gehe ich noch
mal in die von ihnen angeblich so hohe
stelen hin da ist ein krieg in der
ukraine da sind kriegsverbrecher die
wollen wir verfolgen mit
generalbundesanwalt mit
bundesgerichtshof das sind bestellen
wollen sie die nicht oder sagen sie nein
das sind stellen die auch punkt der
gegenwärtigen situation notwendig sind
und wir als cdu haben uns geirrt dass
wir bei diesen stellen nicht mitgemacht
haben das wäre sehr gut wenn sie das an
der stelle
[Applaus]
so und meine damen und herren ich will
zum schluss noch etwas sagen weil es
einfach auf mich ärgert bei der cdu/csu
man könnte jetzt keiner schickte sagen
viel lärm um nichts aber ich will ihnen
das deutlich sagen zum ersten mal seit
16 jahren ist es so dass es der
opposition nicht gelungen ist mehr
änderungen am haushalt durch anträge
vorzunehmen als der koalition sie haben
es als cdu noch nicht einmal geschafft
halb so viele anträge zu stellen wie wir
es als fdp noch in der letzten
legislatur jedes jahr getan haben und um
es zum schluss zu sagen und der rest ist
dann nach schicks beschweigen es war der
cdu csu nicht möglich selbst einem
konzept wirkungsorientierte
haushaltsführung beim bmf zuzustimmen
das wollen sie nicht überlegen sie sich
ob es beim nächsten mal besser machen
jedenfalls müssen sie es besser machen
als in dieser links hatte
otto fricke war das der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der fdp
fraktion und wenn sich hier die ganze
debatte über den gesamten zeitraum
verfolgt haben dann fällt auf dass es
insbesondere fdp und unions redner sind
die sich hier aneinander reiben was den
haushalt angeht und was nicht
stattgefunden hat aus sicht der
unionsfraktion michael schrodi ist der
finanzpolitische sprecher der
spd-fraktion
zuletzt geliefert 44 milliarden
prognostizierte mehreinnahmen höhere
steuereinnahmen im vergleich zur letzten
steuerschätzung wenn man 20 21 und man
muss das schon mal auch deutlich sagen
ich glaube das ist bei aller harten
debatte im detail schon ein ergebnis
einer richtigen krisenpolitik der
letzten jahre gewesen mit
wirtschaftshilfen corona steuer hilfe
gesetzen kurzarbeitergeld
direktzahlungen die firmenpleiten sind
ausgeblieben der arbeitsmarkt ist robust
gerade die neuen zahlen dass die
arbeitslosigkeit auch im mai wieder
gesunken ist und grundlage waren dafür
und sind dafür die massiven
hilfsprogramme investitionen die 20 sich
auch die union begrüßt hat die auch in
vielen stellen die unterstützung hier im
gesamten parlament gefunden haben und
ich glaube es einmal wichtig zu erwähnen
dass der weg der damals richtig war auch
heute weiterhin richtig ist und auf
diesen weg begeben wir uns auch mit
diesem haushalt 20 22 so schön die
zahlen sind muss man auch sagen es sind
natürlich höchst volatil unsicher wir
wissen nicht wie es mit kriegen pandemie
mit der importierten inflation mit zonen
energiepreisen und
lieferketten störungen weiter geht wie
sich wirtschaft entwickelt die
steuereinnahmen sich dann noch
entwickeln eines aber gilt in dieser
krise weiterhin und diese
herausforderungen weiterhin was auf olaf
scholz gesagt hat wir lassen niemanden
allein nicht die bürgerinnen und bürger
und auch nicht die unternehmen in dieser
krise das heißt der finanzplätze
dreiklang unserer applikation heißt
sozialen zusammenhalt stärken
zukunftsinvestitionen weiterhin anpacken
und für eine solide finanzierung sorgen
und diese haushalt bündelt all das genau
und deswegen ist er auch so zu
unterstützt meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren
ich darf heute tieren aus der debatte
zum haushalt 20 21 da hat die union der
fraktionsvorsitzende damals als
brinkhaus überschrift gewählt mit mut
die krise überwinden und gesagt auch
neue schulden müssen aufgenommen werden
um die folgen der krise abzufedern und
in die weiche und die weichen für die
zukunft zu stellen damals war es 240
milliarden wir haben zu einer milliarden
euro weniger was richtig damals war ist
es jetzt auch der haushalt 2022 tut
genau das auch richtig zu investieren
übrigens auch und es verwundert mich
otto fricke hat gesagt der finanz
mittags gesagt
wie kommt es bitteschön dieser massiven
kritik
an einem stellenaufbau beim soll bei der
finanzkontrolle schwarzarbeit bei der
bekämpfung der geldwäsche der zur
kriminalität das von der union ist nicht
nachvollziehen
und das zweite ist heraus da würde ich
aus sicht eines csu los und aus bayern
kommen wirklich ganz ruhig sein
die stellen bei der steuerfahnder über
eine betriebsprüfung da ist grad bayern
ganz weit hinten dran das ist nicht nur
ungerecht sie verzichten auf
steuereinnahmen zu ungunsten der
bayerischen steuerzahler den
steuerzahler und bürger verstoß
tatsächlich
[Applaus]
gestalten wir eine zwischenfrage oder
bemerkungen aus der cdu-fraktion von
halberg
schrodi dass sie die zwischenfrage zu
lassen wenn sie meinen beitrag
sorgfältig zugehört haben habe ich den
stellenaufbau den zusätzlichen von 6000
stellen netto nicht pauschal kritisiert
ich habe das angesprochen habe gesagt
über die dinge kann man den einzelnen
reden trotzdem ist es insgesamt ein
bemerkenswerter aufbau und den muss man
infrage stellen meine frage an sie ist
es denn richtig und das habe ich auch
angesprochen dass sie bei der
einstellung zusätzlicher spitzenbeamten
in den ministerien nicht in
irgendwelchen gerichten irgendwelche
besoldeten richter sondern in den
ministerien mit 324 stellen den rekord
jetzt setzen und ist es richtig dass sie
mit 37
parlamentarischen staatssekretären
hochbezahlt regierungsbeamte jetzt auch
einen rekordwert setzen ist das richtig
und können sie mir das bestätigen
herr mittelberg
zunächst einmal ist es ja schön wenn sie
hier in ihrer rede haben sie das nicht
getan
differenzieren und wenn sie auf endlich
dann deutlich machen dass es richtig ist
dass wir in dem bereich in dem eine es
getan werden muss nämlich bei dem
bereich steuer bild kämpfen
betrugsbekämpfung dass wir den zoll
stärken dass wir hier für mehr
steuergerechtigkeit sorgen übrigens
etwas was im koalitionsvertrag explizit
festgehalten ist dass wir hier etwas tun
wollen beispielsweise auch beim thema
des umsatzsteuerbetrugs dass wir hier
einen stellenaufbau haben der richtig
und notwendig ist zum einen und zum
zweiten wir haben in dieser koalition
eine fortschritts koalition auf den weg
gebracht die deutlich macht wir wollen
große aufgaben angehen und die
ministerien und alles was dazu notwendig
ist muss ordentlichen auch ausgestattet
sein dazu gehört auch eine personelle
ausstattung die wir diesen haushalt auch
gewährleistet ist insofern ist das
richtig dass wir in diesen zeiten gut
ausgestattete ministerien haben wir die
großen aufgaben die zukunftsaufgaben
angehen können und deswegen sind die
investitionen auch das personal hier
wirklich ermittelt
übrigens der haushalt tut auch das was
wichtig ist beim thema investitionen 51
milliarden euro im haushalt sie nach an
zusätzlichen investitionen
enthalten denn nur wer heute investiert
in bildung in weiterbildung nur wenn die
bahn werde wohnungsbau wer in die
erneuerbaren energien investiert der
schafft die voraussetzung dafür dass wir
auch in zukunft
zukunftsfähige unternehmen haben die
arbeitsplätze der zukunft haben und
damit auch die steuer ein wenn von
morgen entsprechend haben auch das ist
eben ein wichtiger beitrag für solide
finanzen der zukunft wenn wir heute
investieren zahlt sich das auch in
zukunft aus und gleichzeitig stellen wir
mit dem haushalt auch inflationsbedingte
mehrausgaben gerade die haushalte mit
kleinen mittleren einkommen sind am
härtesten betroffen von den
preissteigerungen wir haben mit den
leistungspaketen 1 und 2 wir haben mit
dem vierten trainer steuer hilfe gesetzt
von den 44 milliarden mehreinnahmen die
auf zitiert werden allein schon 42
milliarden euro tiefe da an hilfen für
bürgerinnen und bürger für unternehmen
zurück geben und sie gezielt gerade für
kleinere mittlere einkommen zur
verfügung stellen damit wir die hohen
kosten noch abdämpfen für die diese am
härtesten trifft und das ist gut
investiertes geld den sozialen
zusammenhalt meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren
dass er weitere tun wir beobachten die
situation und die entwicklung weiter wir
werden schauen ob wir da weitere hilfen
auch auf den weg bringen müssen 1 bleibt
aber klar auch in zukunft der dreiklang
der heißt soziale zusammenhalt
investitionen möglich machen und darauf
zu nie die finanzen auch schaffen und
mit diesen dreiklang werden wir auch in
den nächsten wochen monate gehen vielen
dank
michael schrodi für die spd-fraktion und
jetzt hat es auch mal zwischen spd und
union gekracht konnte ja nicht
ausbleiben haben bei diesem thema wir
sind in der allgemeinen finanzdebatte es
wird auch diskutiert über den etat des
bundesfinanzministers und des
bundesrechnungshofs aber im grunde das
geht es schon um die ausrichtung der
finanz und haushaltspolitik
insgesamt sebastian schäfer für bündnis
90 die grünen deshalb uld
präsidentin sehr geehrte kolleginnen und
kollegen unser land wurde und wird durch
die korona pandemie und den russischen
angriffskrieg gegen die ukraine extrem
herausgefordert energiepreise steigen
und die probleme bei den lieferketten
haben sich noch einmal verschärft wir
sind gesamtwirtschaftlich leider immer
noch nicht auf vorkrisenniveau angelangt
und die wachstumsprognosen für
2022 wurden teils deutlich nach unten
korrigiert laut dem deutschen industrie
und handelskammertag
beläuft sich der verlust durch die
korona krise bis ende dieses jahres auf
circa 5 145 milliarden euro und das
rechnet die wirtschaftlichen folgen des
brutalen angriffs krieges nicht mit ein
diese bewusst entspricht dem volumen von
anderthalb bundes haushalten vor der
krise und die wirtschaftlichen
perspektiven bleiben schwierig
dementsprechend müssen wir weiter auf
sicht fahren und sollten keine maßnahme
vorschnell ausschließen im gegensatz zum
letzten jahrzehnt erleben wir zudem dass
durch steigende zinsen die spielräume im
bundeshaushalt kleiner werden mit dem
vorliegenden haushaltsentwurf gelingt es
der fortschritts koalition ein
politikwechsel einzuleiten
wir stabilisieren die investitionen auf
dem rekordniveau kollege tobias
angesprochen wir handeln und bekämpfen
die krisen sind international
verlässliche bündnispartner und stärken
sozialen zusammenhalt und klimaschutz
mit in die zukunft gerichteten
investitionen schaffen wir nachhaltiges
wachstum unternehmerisches sicherheit
und damit auf sichere arbeitsplätze
investitionen in den natürlichen
klimaschutz in elektromobilität in die
dekarbonisierung unserer industrie und
in den wasserstoff standort deutschland
helfen nicht nur dem klima damit
unterstützen wir vor allem auch die
transformation der wirtschaft
wir nehmen in diesem jahr nochmals
rekordschulden auf um die bürgerinnen
und bürger angesichts der
preisentwicklung zu entlasten und unsere
extrem herausgeforderten wirtschaft zu
stützen mit dem sondervermögen von 100
milliarden euro wollen wir der
bundeswehr die notwendige ausstattung
zur verfügung stellen insgesamt nehmen
wir neue schulden von fast einer
viertelmillion euro auf nicht
leichtfertig das kann ich unseren
bürgerinnen und bürgern versichern
wir dürfen die fehler der vergangenheit
nicht wiederholen unser staat muss in
den zentralen zukunftsfragen im rahmen
einer ökologisch sozialen
marktwirtschaft auch selbst
verantwortung übernehmen
mit der preisentwicklung insbesondere
bei fossiler energie aber auch bei
lebensmitteln können weitere
entlastungen für die bürgerinnen und
bürger notwendig werden dabei ist es
zentral dass wir diese entlastungen sehr
zielgenau vornehmen die bisherigen
entlassungen müssen wir kritisch
evaluieren und dann entsprechend handeln
dann wird unser land auch durch diese
schwierigen zeiten kommen herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
nächster redner für die cdu/csu-fraktion
christian haase
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen jetzt haben wir
es hier schwarz auf weiß 140 milliarden
neue schulden und wenn wir das die
schulden aus dem sondervermögen da noch
zu rechnen würde das ist nicht so ganz
richtig aber die zu rechnen würde dann
hätten wir leider wieder einen
schuldenrekord und dahinter das hätten
sie sicherlich zu beginn ihrer
amtsübernahme auch anders vorgestellt
dass sie ihren vorgänger dabei noch
überholen dabei hätte die
steuerschätzung der ampel zu mindestens
mittelfristig die möglichkeit gegeben
für entlastungen der bürgerinnen und
bürger zu sorgen und auch die
neuverschuldung zu senken was erleben
wir stattdessen im rahmen der
parlamentarischen beratungen verteilt
die ampel das geld der steuerzahler
steuerzahler völlig ungeniert die
ausgaben des bundes steigen doch mal und
zwölf milliarden euro
nur damit jeder etwas von seiner
wunschliste streichen kann und auch im
personalhaushalt damals nun mehrfach
darauf hingewiesen wird ordentlich drauf
gesattelt brutto fast 10.000 stellen das
kann es an der stelle nicht sein wenn
wir über zeitenwende sprechen und dieses
wort zeitenwende scheint zumindest bei
den appell koalitionären bisher noch
nicht so angekommen zu sein die
aktuellen krisen und herausforderungen
brauchen eine klare antwort und die
bundesregierung liefert uns dabei leider
nur mittelmäßigkeit
was hatten grüne und fdp vor sie wollten
schattenhaushalte auflösen subventionen
streichen die kalte progression
bekämpfen den mittelstandsbauch
abflachen rücklagen auflösen
privatisierungserlöse erzielen
all das hatten sie noch vor kurzem hier
im bundestag gefordert übrig geblieben
ist die einigkeit beim geldausgeben also
meine damen und herren anspruch und
wirklichkeit klappen da doch sehr weit
auseinander und ich will noch einmal
erklären was den zeitenwende bedeutet
man kann nicht so weiter machen wie
bisher das ist die aussage von
zeitenwende wir hatten komme aus einer
zweijährigen weltweiten pandemie wir
erleben die rückkehr der inflation die
wirtschaftsleistung stagniert und wir
haben krieg in europa und erleben dies
kann politik keine richtige konkrete
entlastungen die bei bürgerinnen und
bürgern ankommt ich will nur als ein
beispiel dass neun euro ticket nehmen
zweieinhalb milliarden die vollkommen
verpuffen an der stelle da wird man
keine pendler in den op en v mit rein
bekommen da hätten wir den bv anders
helfen können
wie wir nach der gießkanne politik
2023 zur schuldenbremse zurückkommen
wollen das ist mir unergründlich und
trotzdem wir wollen mit dieser
bundesregierung auch unsere
staatspolitische verantwortung zeigen es
ist mehrfach heute angesprochen worden
ich bin froh dass wir uns beim
bundesheer sondervermögen geeinigt haben
denn diese schulden sind die richtige
antwort auf die wiederherstellung der
verteidigungsfähigkeit in deutschland an
der stelle und deshalb ist es auch
gerechtfertigt diese 100 milliarden
zusätzliche schulden aufzunehmen und wir
erkennen auch an dass es in diesem jahr
noch notwendig war ein letztes und ein
wirklich ein allerletztes mal die
schuldenbremse auszusetzen wir sind mit
der begründung die wir jetzt gelesen
haben nicht ganz einverstanden
insbesondere das thema inflation wird
jetzt alleine aus der ukraine krise her
gelöst das glaube ich ist ein wenig
scheuklappen an der stelle ich glaube
die installation hat mehr gründe als die
ukraine krise und deswegen müssen wir
aufpassen dass wir da finanzpolitisch
auch letztendlich darauf reagieren aber
wenn der 115 grundgesetz jetzt schon die
möglichkeit lässt über die konjunktur
komponente hinaus schulden aufzunehmen
dann heißt das ja nicht automatisch das
dann dass man das vollständig machen
muss dass man jede möglichkeit die
dahinter steckt jetzt auch ausnutzen
muss das hätte man anders lösen können
und dann geht es auch darum dass wir das
finanzgefüge mit den ländern noch mal
wieder in den blick nehmen die länder
schon seit zwei jahren machen
überschüsse während der bund hohe
schulden aufnimmt da hätte ich mehr
ansätze gewünscht wo man dagegen angehen
kann und auch das thema stelle möchte
jetzt hier noch einmal klarstellen war
das heute morgen der studie vielleicht
hören sie eben zu heute morgen
wiederholt falsch dargestellt wurde wir
machen den vorschlag ein prozent
stelleneinsparung 1 prozent
stelleneinsparung und wer unsere anträge
gelesen hat wird auch gelesen haben dass
wir zum beispiel den zoll auch wenn das
heute mehrfach falsch gesagt wurde und
das bka von diesen stellen einsparungen
auswählen und jetzt kollege otto fricke
du hast dich eben beklagt dass wir zu
wenig anträge gestellt hätten und du
siehst die sind dann ja noch nicht mal
gelesen worden also wir wollten auch
nicht überfordern an der stelle weil wir
arbeiten an der stelle mit mehr qualität
und weniger quantität und letzter punkt
noch mal in richtung des kollegen show
die wallis gesagt haben die ampel selbst
hat ja den antrag gestellt 0,5 prozent
stellen in den ministerien einzusparen
also insofern auch da vielleicht mal mit
den kollegen noch etwas genauer
abstimmen herr kollege haase erlauben
sie eine zwischenfrage oder bemerkung
von otto fricke
herr kollege hase im ersten danke ich
dass sie ausdrücklich klargestellt haben
dass sie die einprozentige pauschale
stellenkürzungen gemacht haben nachdem
sie gesehen hatten dass die koalition
sich auf die 0,5 geeinigt haben meine
frage ist jetzt aber kann ich aus ihrer
äußerung ausschließen dass es zutrifft
dass sie ebenso wenige anträge gestellt
haben im vergleich zur opposition und
das schließt die grünen im letzten jahr
ja auch mit 1 und b schließlich dann
daraus dass sie entgegen der äußerung
des kollegen mittelberg sie sagen also
bis auf
1 prozent die 99 prozent der stellen
erhöhung der koalition sind richtig
also wir machen eine solide politik und
genau wahrscheinlich wie sich die ampel
koalition mit den 0,5 prozent mal ein
wenig an das thema ran gewagt haben
haben wir uns mit dem 1 prozent daran
gewagt werden noch zwei prozent
schreiben können aber wir sehen ja auch
realitäten an der stelle und es wäre
besser gewesen die stellen erst gar
nicht aus zu bringen oder etwas anderes
zu tun an der stelle das hätte man tun
können haben sie nicht getan aber das
ist ja dann ihre entscheidung als 0,5
prozent nachher einzukassieren
und ich hab da mal im
bundesfinanzministerium nachgefragt wenn
wir schon zusätzliche schulden wegen
corona und das war ja bis zum zweiten
regierungsentwurf der inhalt wenn wir
schon zusätzliche schulden wegen corona
aufnehmen können was ich das denn alles
und ein gutteil haken dran haken dran
haken dran relativ enger zusammenhang
zur corona krise aber auf der liste die
mir dann zur verfügung gestellt wurde
fand ich auch das online zugangs gesetz
mit fast zwei milliarden euro
corona bedingt register modernisierung
mit 48 millionen und flotten
erneuerungsprogramm behörden schiffe 224
millionen da ich schon viel kreativität
beim schuldenmachen gefragt um denn
alles letztendlich mit der korona krise
zu begründen meine damen und herren ich
glaube wir hätten an der stelle mehr
machen können meyer hat ja eben
richtigerweise gesagt was man an der
stelle alles tut wir wollen die kalte
progression abbauen wir wollen die
energiepreis pauschale auch für rentner
und studenten familienzuschuss auf 200
euro verdoppeln entlastungsbetrag für
alleinerziehende und wie finanzieren wir
das mit der rücklage die jetzt
eingesetzt werden muss denn nicht für
zukünftige neue aufgaben sondern wir
müssen sie jetzt einsetzen und den
bürgerinnen und bürger das angesparte
geld zurückgeben und weil sie das ebenso
ausdrücklich gesagt haben gehe ich davon
aus dass nicht nur sie gleich unserem
entschließungsantrag auch zustimmen
werden
und er linda sie haben jetzt die schwere
aufgabe nächstes jahr tatsächlich die
schuldenbremse einzuhalten das heißt es
ist ja gar nicht nächstes jahr im grunde
ist der haushalt ja schon fast fertig an
der stelle und wir sind darauf gespannt
wie das funktionieren kann wir sehen den
druck wenn ich sehe dass er heil in den
letzten tagen das heute morgen herr
rudolph und der kindler schon wieder
forderungen an den neuen haushalt
gestellt haben der noch gar nicht
veröffentlicht
jubelt ja schon das schuldenbremsen aus
auf europäischer ebene
dann weiß ich dass das eine ganz
schwierige aufgabe wird das auch
tatsächlich durchzuhalten wir wollen das
machen sie haben es letztens noch einmal
wiederholt für sie gilt lieber an neue
wahlen als neue schulden und dann warten
wir mal ab dankeschön
christian haase war das der
haushaltspolitische sprecher der
unions-fraktion einer seiner konkreten
kritikpunkte 6000 stellen neu in
ministerien und behörden das behagte der
union und auch den anderen
oppositionsparteien nicht so wirklich
ein anderes beispiel sind die kosten für
den g 7 gipfel die war mit 50 millionen
veranschlagt jetzt sind 30 mehr das
ganze findet ja im sommer in schloss
elmau stadt und vor 20.15 hat es gerade
mal 15 millionen gekostet da fragt man
sich natürlich auch wo das dann herkommt
frauke heiligenstadt ist am pult für die
spd fraktion
woche verabschiedet wird mein kollege
michael schrodi hat das schon ausgeführt
hat einen dreiklang einen dreiklang aus
drei verschiedenen schwerpunkten einmal
die krisenbewältigung
einmal die
zukunftsinvestitionen und einmal die
förderung des gesellschaftlichen
zusammenhalts und dieser dreiklang macht
das besondere eines solchen haushaltes
aus in der ampel regierung
ich komme gleich auf die einzelnen
punkte noch zu sprechen ich möchte
allerdings weil in den letzten
debattenbeiträgen ja immer darauf
eingegangen wurde was wir ausgeben
einmal die einnahmeseite auch beleuchten
zu den haupteinnahmequellen gehören
einmal die steuern in einem staat und
ich denke dass man auch gerade auch als
letzte rednerin in dieser debatte einmal
arbeiten denn in den finanzverwaltungen
und in den finanzämtern der länder ganz
herzlich danken kann denn die müssen
jeden tag steuer ein
einbeziehen und sie müssen unsere
politischen vorgaben umsetzen
ich danke auch natürlich den
steuerzahlen den bürgerinnen und bürgern
denn sie sind es die dafür sorgen dass
wir gemeinsam unsere aufgaben hier
erledigen können nämlich die wichtigen
staatlichen aufgaben und die sich nicht
darum herum drücken und versuchen
steuern zu hinterziehen
das heißt also steuerehrlichkeit ist
sehr wichtig für unseren staat und dafür
gilt es auch einmal danke zu sagen
deshalb ist es zum beispiel auch gut
dass wir die voraussetzungen schaffen um
noch besser steuergerechtigkeit zum
durchbruch zu verhelfen indem wir zum
beispiel
1400 neue stellen es ist schon ein paar
mal erwähnt wurden für die
zollverwaltung aufgelegt haben das ist
ein kampf für mehr steuergerechtigkeit
gegen geldwäsche gegen zwei kriminalität
gegen terrorismus finanzierung aber
und das sei mir gestattet auch aus der
perspektive der sozialdemokratischen
fraktion hier in diesem haus das
deutlich zu machen auch die zweit und
die finanzkontrolle schwarzarbeit
zuständig dafür dass wir die
durchsetzung des mindestlohns auf den
baustellen und in den betrieben
kontrollieren können auch das ist
wichtig der wird im übrigen ab oktober
12 euro betragen und das ist gut so
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
der bund wird in 2022 345 milliarden
euro steuern einnehmen das sind immerhin
knapp 17 milliarden euro mehr als noch
vor einem halben jahr geschätzt und die
nettokreditaufnahme wird knapp 140
milliarden euro seien all das sind
immerhin deutlich bessere zahlen als wir
sie noch vor einem halben jahr erwarten
konnten das zeigt dass wir auch viele
wichtige maßnahmen in der pandemie
umgesetzt haben die richtig waren zum
beispiel das kurzarbeitergeld damit
menschen gar nicht erst in die
entsprechenden hilfesysteme hinein
gerutscht sind das war wichtig sie
standen einfach sofort wieder den
betrieben nach einem schnellen
aufschwung nachdem
nach der zäsur in der pandemie zur
verfügung wir konnten damit viele
entlassungen vermeiden
die zahlen zeigen auch dass wir mit dem
unternehmens beihilfen richtig gelegen
haben denn auch die schnelle
wirtschaftliche erholung hat dazu
beigetragen dass die steuereinnahmen
deutlich gestiegen sind und dass wir
steuern mehr einnahmen haben und damit
auch die aufgaben des staates schultern
können ist natürlich grundsätzlich
positiv andererseits bereitet und die
steigende inflation sehr große sorgen
die preise für lebensmittel und energie
sind besonders für familien und menschen
mit geringem einkommen so exorbitant
gestiegen dass ihnen teilweise nicht
mehr wissen wie sie am ende des monats
mit dem einkommen noch klar kommen
müssen deshalb haben wir zwei
entlastungs paket auf den weg gebracht
und meine sehr verehrten kolleginnen und
kollegen der union das ist da nicht
nichts das sind 3 milliarde euro
entlastung oder direkte zuschüsse für
menschen mit kleinen einkommen und das
ist richtig so denn die menschen
profitieren von der senkung der
strompreise durch den wegfall der ewige
umlage sie profitieren von dem tank
rabatt sie profitieren von dem neuen
euro ticket und ich weiß ehrlich gesagt
gar nicht was die cdu alles mit den
kosten für das 9 euro ticket finanzieren
will in jedem fall weiß ich aber dass
millionen von bestellungen und besteller
das neue euro ticket schon gelöst haben
und deswegen sagen die wir nehmen dieses
neuen euro ticket an und das ist auch
richtig so wir werden
wir werden weiterhin die lage aufmerksam
beobachten und ich bin dem
bundesarbeitsminister hubertus heil sehr
dankbar dass er am wochenende zu dem
thema eines sozialen klima geldes
vorschläge gemacht hat auch das wird
etwas sein was möglicherweise zur
entlastung in den kommenden monaten wenn
es notwendig ist beitragen kann meine
sehr verehrten damen und herren denn wir
bereiten 1 im blick die menschen mit
mittleren und kleinen einkommen die sind
extrem wichtig bei der betrachtung der
steuerpolitik vielen dank für die
aufmerksamkeit
sie sagt frauke heiligenstadt werden aus
der spd-fraktion und damit ist diese
debatte beendet es geht um die ein und
andere abstimmung
und zwar zunächst über den einzelplan 08
bundesministerium der finanzen in der
ausschuss fassung wer stimmt für diesen
einzuplanen das ist die spd fraktion
bündnis 90 die grünen und die fdp
fraktion wäre stimmt dagegen das ist die
afg fraktion cdu csu und die fraktion
die linke damit ist der einzelplan 08
angenommen wir kommen nun zur abstimmung
über den einzelplan 2 sich der
bundesrechnungshof wer stimmt für diesen
einzelplan
das sind alle fraktionen gibt es
enthaltungen
gegen stimmen dann ist dieser einzelplan
20 einstimmig angenommen